you said everything with your
actions D
rules do you play Dungeons and Dragons
yeah oh yeah didn't you used to yeah I
have like an online game with some
friends we play every other week how's
that you would DM right I am
yeah you write the whole story right
kind of am I tried I tried playing
dungeon dragons Dungeons and Dragons
with um with Michael Millet and
Maria all them good group and Mona oh
we've never got past character sheets
yeah that's that's typical that's pretty
typical you have to get like three
sessions in and then you're good and I
was like I just want to play and I
thought it'd be funny to make my
character stupid but nobody liked that
idea like that's
problematic you're making women look bad
no but also it's like people like game
it you know they want you to be
effective and like even though it's yeah
yeah that's what why they were yeah
like because they want to win for some
reason which is like not so
dumb trying to so you want to do a shot
yeah yeah let's do it all
right cheers check to the land of Katan
yeah not an effective shot glass yeah
this one has like a
RI that's funny it's more for sugar
cubes you get this out of the way I
actually think I I didn't finish my show
I didn't I didn't want anyone to know
but I
didn't busted
let's roll the
D roll the D go first just roll one oh
do you go first did that well no I mean
I haven't we haven't done the roll yet
oh
yeah
seven we're rolling both dice now 10
you only you usually only roll one yeah
11 it really doesn't
matter
nine I even look at the board
yet it's the standard board that comes
in the packaging or in the pictures the
sticker
oh
a glare off of
those the what the ring light is messing
with me really yeah that better yeah I
can see it from down here I just got to
crouch
um lot of good spots yeah the default
setting of the board is it's well
balanced yeah
weird almost like they designed
it um
[__]
me the chaos of the
random it's a good
spot I was so focused on where you were
going to go I wasn't thinking about
where I'm going to go mhm you're playing
a g great game if you're
Heather got to get inside of her
head
so Zach you recently posted a picture of
your dog I did was that a new year thing
yeah I picked him up I adopted him a
year ago today on near I did yeah nice
it's very
fun that's great is that the dog that uh
Daniel was like running around with or
is that another dog no was his dog his
dog just happens to look just like mine
yeah it's like when my mom visited me a
few months ago
go Dan like she'd seen pictures of my
the first time she met my dog and Dan's
dog like ran up to her and she literally
said like like she didn't believe me
when I said that was not my dog cuz he
was in my the crate the other room where
am I going to go the old switcher Ro the
old switcher she was like Zach you're
not funny yeah shut up jokes don't
work really hurts
mom oh
Mom
yeah I guess right
here go towards the
port
10 this is a great concept for a podcast
just four people staring at a
board thinking really hard there's
people commenting on this are there they
think we're on drugs Lis Lopez says
everyone is on drugs is that about the
podcast or like in general everyone in
the world yeah from Oklahoma I'm from
Oklahoma doesn't it [__]
suck
leis [__]
like now I love the wind on the
weat I thought that was
[Laughter]
hilarious Heather stop trying to be
funny we're thinking right now yeah he
Oklahoma sucks he said it yeah thanks
[Laughter]
lewiis
Tito's vodka Tito's Handmade Vodka
yeah future sponsor of this Katan
podcast as well as
Starbucks and
Oreos and Lone Star those would be that
would be amazing we'd be
holy [__] Katan has yet to get back to
us but
Oreos please keep eating more Oreos on
air your turn all right what we got here
all
right oh I'm gonna get [__] this
game all right H tra me in like he does
I need uh I need these three resources
so
work want
sh so this is my new house I got it cuz
my friend went back home and decided to
give it to me um she her lease ends in
February so she's like you can stay in
here while I wait for it to EXP Spire
nice what what's better this or a van
this yeah yeah
obviously it's just the good thing about
the van is the price yeah that that
makes sense are you I don't want to ask
if you're I'm sure you're what is this
address in yeah what's
a someone saying they're going to kill
themselves in the
comments do it you should yeah you
you're watching this podcast you kind of
should they saying your volume's
down mine yeah said you're quiet oh
that's just yeah we're playing in
Settlers of
Katan oh was it my turn this is so
depressing I'm so
depressed how do you think we what's
more depressing you guys tuning in or us
like reading these
comments I [__] me dude I I need a need
a sheep in
it I need a sheep in it what else do I
need and
wood so straight out the bottle you guys
want to why don't you want to see
Spider-Man what if we saw Spider-Man
after
this after would be fine yeah I didn't I
just didn't want to watch a movie for 2
and 1 half hours that's true it's long
I've already seen it but I'd see it
again if you guys wanted to go see it
yeah I like the part with uh is
Spider-Man yeah when he does this I like
that part he says Fizz yeah
Fizz it would have been better if we saw
Spider-Man first though we we could
spoil it on the podcast that would be
good I'm thinking they there okay when I
found out Iron Man Died In Avengers go
there I wrote it on Facebook but and
people got genuinely pissed off but
that's said two so that's yeah it's not
cool
dude plus I want to go there you [__]
with me Hans are you yeah it came from
Place
security you're going for the Sheep huh
no nothing you're really [__] me
you're going for two sheep right out
right out of the
gate I need want the port yeah I want
the port but also I need to be on wood
but that's the only wood over there yeah
[Music]
this
see H five is a lucky number of Katan
yeah all right [__] it the Katan Gods
like the number five I'm just go this
way I don't give a [__] did you put the
resources in the like default places too
I start off with two sheet yeah that
[__] sucks
okay oh wa it's going to be a great
comeback how was oh yeah how that goes
first how was the creek yesterday it was
so much fun oh it was wild yeah it was a
good time time that's a fun space yeah
there's so many people there yeah I
hugged and kissed a lot of people yeah I
Kissed A lot of people I do that when
I'm drunk I need to cut it out 11 10
10 I was just
joking I didn't kiss anyone I kissed
someone last
night oh yeah that's true gay everyone
at this table has kissed Patrick that's
that is a fact
the only people who haven't kissed at
this table are Zach and H oh do I get a
t-shirt you kissed me now we got
something to um I'm going to build a
road how the [__] did you get so many
resources so fast uh just every number
has been rolled I've got Jesus Christ
look at this I'm an idiot I'm
sorry uh or
always tell us about you guys my mother
died when I was 19 years Cal down calm
down right it and I found her it
is I was molested when I was six by my
neighbor who was
nine does that even count it does I
don't know I don't know I never counted
it my therapist counts it you don't have
a therapist I don't you don't feel a
doctor what' Your Role uh it is three
your turn it is interesting
that for the for sake the conduit where
we all started in New Hampshire in New
England what the [__] Patrick like 3
years ago 10 10 yeah
um rock what were you saying never mind
I was trying to introduce us and say why
yeah us three started in New England
around the same exact time doing comedy
we are comedians as well and we moved to
Austin a year moved together no we all
followed Dan Butler we all followed Zach
Dan follow Dan come on
I followed Dan bowler I'm sorry 11 Dan
followed me oh my boy my boy is going to
Austin T well you can go back to New
Hampshire then and see Dan Butler shout
out to Dan Butler is that the person
that was your roommate yeah yeah he died
does any work at a grilled cheese food
truck no he di he used to but he
died no he moved back to New Hampshire
That's crazy cuz he's like the quietest
one I didn't know you guys all follow he
most quiet you think yeah who else
that's because you didn't see him he was
quiet socially just by not showing up so
he came here to but when he was
comfortable he was
comedy
basically no he's uh is it my turn oh
yeah I'm done Z oh did you roll or yeah
I rolled to
11 two oh I get a sheep dude I've
got does anyone have any weats they want
to trade oh no
I do not okay I have but one card how do
you have so many cards already what's
going on here I'm getting lucky baby
seven how many cars I have seven I'm
good do you I do see
look show you
my it's fine you don't know what they
were there's a lot of rock there's a lot
of
rock it was a lot of rock don't give him
wheat there's a reason he wants wanted
wheat I have one you're an [__] you
have wood no I don't want to steal from
you then he was lying you have wood oh
[__] anyone have wood
no guys I have brick and sheep if anyone
wants wood or has wood I don't have I
only have
sheepies sheep I'll take what is this
what do we brick and a rock if you want
a w had a wood yeah [__] he lied but
I'll give you a I'll give you the wood
for a brick and a rock I don't have it I
give you two brick two brick for one
wood I'll do it you
[__] can't believe you lied to
me that's how you play Katan right there
you lie you lie thought I hit you in the
face it's your turn that's their
official slogan [__] lieing to your
best friends all right three
three yellow band is funny
oh did I not oh no I
did I thought I didn't go on any hay
um no you can
go Liars of Katan
nice or is that leers of
Kat Liars of Katan they all said they
were comedians
yeah what' you get five five was a good
I don't have
five lovely
okay I can't
[Music]
do
eight oh you [__] you stupid [__] um
okay go
ahead eight go
ahead can't do
anything 10 n math nine oh nice oh math
Hans
Louis that's
why does anybody have a wood or what a
hay they want to
trade what is that what do you need a
wood or a hay no I'm good I do but I'm
good
yeah no wait am I on a port calm
down calm down with your adjusting
you're on the brick port two for one
anybody have a brick they want to give
me for what um I'll give you a brick
um you have a wheat or a wood or a rock
I have a
sheep
no I no I need my rock okay you can
go eight again oh my God D [__] got
me it's a good
robber um you can go
uh six all right I got a Breck okay
answering that question I I feel like
I'm on NPR to answer your question I
can't read your name my shirt says dwarf
Cannon friend shout out to kenona and
his punk band that I've literally never
listened to it's pretty good actually
it's good he just gave me a free
shirt listen all you listeners out there
10 10 all right go watch Ken's Clips on
Instagram and don't follow him
though wait did you say 10 I just build
a settlement that's the action done oh
my [__] god
10 eat a
pizza we're playing Katan Settlers of
Katan it's a Bo game why you watching
this if you never heard of
Katan they're fans of
Hans that is so funny like only people
who play kitan can watch this what a
niche
audience I bet there's a lot of
crossover between fans of Han and Hans
and fans of
K I didn't like his comedy but when he
said he played Katan that's connected
with
me uh three
three oh I got a w interesting I didn't
know I had the same numbers on both
sides [__]
hey no one has hay not at all none you
have brick
um yeah what well two brick for one
wheat I don't have two bricks okay I'm
just going to play my night card why
it's in such a good place it is
[__] wait till the night's on
you that's true but I already did it I
feel like a [__] idiot if I go back
on that oh my God I'm just going to try
and steal one of your
haes give me
me oh my
god oh [__] I I didn't
even I swear to God I didn't even see
it all right I'm just going to buy a
development Cod or I mean a yeah
whatever the [__] it's
called you good H yeah you can
play what is it eight eight finally I
had to use my eight [__] I should have
kept it there I know idiot God you're
dumb that who here
smokes I slightly do I can't smoke a lot
there was that one time we played Katan
and I was hitting your bong and I had a
ginormous panic attack on the right home
it was fun Patrick watch who was there
for that how did what did how did it
manifest itself I don't know I we went
and got McDonald's and then I ate one
thing and then like had to recline and
just
panic and breathe a lot it was
fun don't do drugs have to panic guys
they call it a panic attack but has
anyone ever done a panic
defense [__]
Zach hey guys hey hey three years of
[Laughter]
Comedy I'm all
set I used to smoke but then I found my
mother dead when I was
high eight
does anyone have a wheat you wanted to
know about me now you know wheat be
careful what you ask for I
don't um
H all right I guess I'm
done eight damn dude so many you want
sheep anyone for wood for Brick hey h
can I just say I'm so sorry for moving
that night really hope that development
card was worth it oh I'm done
okay well now we know where to put it
yeah
seven well I got to lose half my cards
nice who am I stealing
from
what what do you have nine you give away
four yeah I'm G to steal from wait where
are you
guys I'm going to steal from
Zachary oh the Heartbreak of
Katan um it's it's not who said it was
like boring D and D no it's like a
little bit less boring Monopoly is more
what it's like all right yeah weat a you
[__] son of this really mean you know
we're trying to have fun here
Andor I always do
this what are you doing why is that road
so long you want to pass the
D um
um I'm going to get a development
card all right one a [__] I forgot about
put development
cards [__] I forgot I did what you doing
what oh sorry I thought you wereing them
four there's two blue shirt
guys what's the blue what's the blue
shirt guy comment yeah he a blue shirt
guy is signaling with an ear pull two
two of us have blue shirts idiot anyone
want wheat or sheep for Brick anyone
want have brick
um no for what what do you want wheat or
sheep I'll do it for
wheat
okay
okay Hans they're saying this is boring
AF yeah well you got to go through the
pain period to get to the juicy content
in the middle that's fair what do you
think I'm signaling with the ear pole
take a
guess um I'm going to buy another
development
card I don't know why doing that but to
do it sorry Christopher
Casto um didn't mean to be so aggressive
towards
you how are we
aggressive I mean they all joke around I
shirts you [__] idiot oh
that's yeah you guys I just are you guys
watching this you should kill yourselves
I just need to take any chance I can to
bully someone else cuz cuz I get it all
the
time oh oh bucket comments is a good uh
that's a good
insult six he called us bucket Comics
which is just good pretty give it to you
that's really funny that is pretty it's
good
solid [__] it I remember my
days been on kill Tony twice all
right it was
random wait who just rolled that didn't
you no I rolled that to six I'm done
sorry wait one second
actually wait okay never mind are you
done no I can sorry what's your Ro is
now seven but all right then I want a
seven so you
know why do you keep building
roads build a
settlement all right Heather block him
off and build a settlement right there
yeah do it yeah I'm not getting any good
cards cuz I didn't go on the [__]
wood
idiot what do I have here one little
sheep give me that uh [__] up
hard give me the little thing that uh
tells you how to build
things please please please Hans would
you why don't you go ahead and give me
that right
now build a
road right
here good
move
seven
um okay back blue or front
blue this is important [__] blue dude
and also what about
me
wood on a sale from Patrick I'm kidding
obviously obviously it's it's
front get sheep [__] anyone have brick
or
wood um
no
no what do you got to trade sheep
no I'm
good oh David you [__] what you
betrayed me the guy in the blue is hot
which blue yeah he said
back back oh thank you thank you it's
hot in here than it Hans keeps it hot in
here did you guys like that joke cool it
down
funny wasn't that hilarious am I still
attractive
now
oh
okay thank
you okay I'm done you can go
Heather all
righty can you be can you be racist in
YouTube chats or what will it censor
only if you try really hard somebody try
you're behind a fake name and a I mean
your Gmail is LED in there yeah I have a
job no you guys be racist and then we
won't have to
be I have
fake this
guy pays attention all right a gay man
the other day said I had the best
eyelashes and that's going to fuel me
the rest of my
life with the narciss did you pick up
the wheat uh what' you roll I rolled a
nine oh no I didn't I was thinking about
my eyelashes yeah yeah we got that
classic pretty Bo um is the North Korean
food joke supposed to be racist not
racist enough not what I was looking for
all right Patrick I'm stealing from you
a monkey emoji now that's that's what I
was looking
for and now I'm getting stolen
from because
I made fun of black people so that's
what happens when you that is what
happens oh wait do M no I can't [__]
do
anything um does anyone have any wood no
or brick you shouldn't have stolen from
me I have the worst resources right now
shut
up anybody
no Zachary I kind of need all my oh my
God so how do you guys write
jokes dude I haven't been writing
lately it's really bad haven't you seen
our sets we don't
we're [__] bucket
comedians you just grab words from a
bucket and make it into a joke uh I just
say stories from real life and I think
that's funnier than anything any normal
comedian could
say I watch what other Comics do and I
just kind of mimic what they
do I just watch Lou CK and write
down and then you jerk off in front yeah
and then I jerk off in front of women
talk about how I hate my kids with it I
don't know what he's
doing
seven
interesting very
interesting all right all right Zachary
benette good job bud what did he
say
Jesus
oh
interesting I like
it I'm all set I
man um I'm doing I'm doing bad I'm down
bad on this one seven God damn all right
where am we
going did you one
yeah you should have kept the the one I
had cuz that that lip is sucks lip is
not
um I guess I'll steal from head [__] off
hey h you bu nothing Hans has a bunch of
wheat no I don't has so much
wheat
nine
wheat any want have
brick what wood
yeah
[Music]
um does it say how many people are
watching yeah but I don't like to see
that okay you don't want like to see how
low it is yeah you don't or how high it
is I'd rather it be high that would that
would make me feel better it's s
wrecking oh no I'm uh that would make me
feel better about having to walk in fact
Hans Kim is actually
Nigerian and he hits babies
often I whack babies off yeah I'm true
is Hans Kim an Asian
person we think
so are any Asians
people I haven't met one
yet we got a [__] s in the comments
thank you for letting us know Goa the
amount of people appreciate
that oh that is so nice D that is nice
get out of here David you're not a
comedian what is it get
kindhearted um sped on us that's what we
want
nine um I'm going to play another night
I'm going to take that largest army oh
God give me give me give me he's got
four
points in the [__] lead with zero
wood can you believe it
ladies I threw my game
away can you believe a woman is doing
something with no wood with no
one [__] off um that was that was a
penis joke that was a penis joke that's
so
funny Hans how do you write jokes cuz
you do it very
well thanks it's like I'm to steal from
I do a lot of communist stuff yeah
see it's good um I I right does that
mean that we can use your jokes cuz it's
for the
people um I get paid fairly for my
wages because I labored and toiled for
it yeah you do for my
labor
six oh Jesus
Christ I haven't gotten like
four I haven't gotten a card in a while
four I'm going to I write 2,000 words
every day into my little phone from like
a little Bluetooth keyboard is that true
yeah that's awesome I tried to do it
every day yeah I Jesse Burling game was
saying that there's like an app or Holly
was telling me that Jesse uses an app
that like you write and if you take time
to like stop writing it deletes
everything you just wrote so it like
forces you to write yeah which sounds
nice but I feel like I I'm way too ADHD
for that [__] um I'm going to play year
of Plenty to get two racks and then I'm
going to did you just say he said it's
easy to write when you're good [__] you
dude and then I'm going to build a oh
wait is that not a disc on us I just
took it as a disc cuz I hate myself I'm
sorry um there you go
seven
[__] I find like most of the
jokes I write are like just walking
through life and then I see something
crazy and I'm like oh that's I should
write that down mhm You observe the
world yeah we all do my best jokes come
when I'm either sad or when I'm just
laying in bed and forcing myself to
think
it's really lame for me to say this but
I do I think of almost all my jokes
while I'm
exercising like 90% of them like isame
better than I know I'm getting swole
yeah you're like man my body's so sexy I
tried to joke about that all of his
jokes all my
jokes all jokes are like so his leg day
today oh my left tricep said to my right
Quadra sub I just flew in and boy my
arms aren't tired at
all I'm very strong
[Laughter]
chat
um it is under underscore it counts
five throw some Street jokes in the chat
wait what was everybody somebody write a
street joke in there oh okay you don't
know any
sevens when the seven is rolled uh you
move the thief and then get to steal a
resource from another player I like the
podcast voice yeah does it sound nice
soothing to your ears
listeners what about the
vacuum don't tell them what don't give
him advice on how to play Katan you
asshol don't mansplain Katan
I could do this oh
it's what what what's your favorite
Street joke
anyone I don't know I told you m mine
the other night it's a good
one say classic joke not going to leave
the this is seven again all the street
jokes I know are racist because I'm from
Boston the the streets are racist in
Boston the streets are racist yeah um
Street jokes you mean those guys who
hang out on the
corner all right I'm going to steal from
you
Zachary uh my my favorite Street joke
it's very clean and good is a a man is
trying to sell his uh dog to another man
and he says it's a it's a talking dog
and the guy other man says prove it and
he says okay what's on top of a house
roof roof roof he goes okay what does a
sandpaper field like feel like rough Ru
rough and he goes who's the greatest
baseball player of all time Ruth Ruth
Ruth and the guy goes get out of here
you're obviously lying and they kick him
out and the guy and the dog says should
I have said J
deio it's an amazing great joke all
great jokes end with everyone going good
joke yeah well Street jokes are weird
because it's an amazing joke that's such
a well structured joke that was written
by one guy everyone else was was like
that's really good I'm going to tell
everyone that joke take the credit and
no one gets credit for that great joke
nope you have any brick I don't have
anything what the [__] I have nothing I
haven't picked up a card in forever no
it's been like 8 sevens roll all right
just [__] I'm already accepting my
loss eight it's about [__] time I my
brother used to tell me this bad joke
that I loved I might butcher it right
now but it was like uh a piece of rope
walks into a bar and the bartender said
get the [__] out of here you stupid
[__] rope and he leaves and he comes
back with a with a dis with like a with
fake glasses and a wig and he goes into
the bar and he goes hey aren't you that
piece of [__] rope get the [__] out and
so he leaves and he ties himself in a
knot and phrases his ends and then goes
back into the bar and the bartender says
hey aren't you that piece of rope and he
goes no I'm afraid not
10m uh anyone have any brick it's a good
joke it's a great joke I love it and
nobody gets credit for it I know I don't
have any [__]
brick I would say you only messed up
that you said Fray You should have said
like messed up like the top of the oh
yeah nine
yeah I
guess any have
sheep I have sheep you want wood do you
have brick C joke you just want us to
say [__] uh piece of [__]
no I'll give you a sheep for
wood
thanks yes an
Oreo
spored why did the roofer uh why was the
rooster uh happy when the cat fell in
the
well because [__] loves wet
[__] I rolled a five that's a oh I get
a brick baby
and I get a
sh
godamn o I finally have stuff to
do [__] [__]
me does anybody have a
brick yeah are you sure yeah yes yes you
do yeah I'm not going to give it to you
why
not man okay
well okay I [__] up hard on this game
and I'm really starting to realize
that build the [__]
road all right you can
go five again
does anybody have a wheat wait what por
do I have I'll trade a brick for a wheat
brick por you want a brick I want a
brick or a
stone you a stone for a
week o
[Music]
baby build
a
settlement so Hans you used to be in
both Washington and New York right
like what is how's Austin differ from
those scenes Austin's more Rough and
Tumble people say [__] here yeah
everyone says [__] hereone New York
they don't say [__] Seattle they don't
say [__] uh Seattle is like [__] uh
really PC and like really hoyy toyy and
they're like all the way up there and no
one really thinks about them so they're
they're like snobby and they're like
we're better than everyone and they
don't socialize I'm half gay so I feel
like I can say [__] but I don't know I
I did a show Once where I uh I turned to
someone in the front row and I said
something like uh I was like I don't
want to bully you guys cuz I like you
and I went um I said to a woman like I'm
sorry for calling a [__] earlier and
then I turned to a guy and I said did I
call you [__] and he was like were you
thinking it I was like yeah I was and
then later I found out he was there on a
fully gay date and I was like Oh I
thought he was straight like that was
would have been so funny called Gay not
and then I came out later cuz I was
hosting and I was like I was like a I
was like I committed the hate crime
tonight and we're all just going to have
to deal with that and I'm half gay maybe
it's okay but but I don't think it
is 10 he could have been acting [__]
though he really wasn't like I thought I
thought he was like Macho so I was like
oh this is going to like hurt his
feelings dude gay people are so Macho
now gay people gay people are [__]
Macha all right let me do a thing I mean
it's a strong it's a strong move to put
a dick in your mouth what's more manly
than that yeah
true I'm such a
man
what a horrible move but
clink holy [__] I'm [__] winning
idiots eight 1 two three four five right
one two three 4 one
two three two three
four wait what the f is Hans winning one
2 3 four five no no we're tied he's
about to get longest road though by a
lot have a we
no does anybody have a wheat no I
literally only have sheep I'll give you
a brick for a wheat I'm good I give you
a brick for a wheat I'm good I'll give
you anything any resource you want for a
wheat any resources can I do a brick you
want a brick for a week no I'm just
kidding oh that's
awful
oh wait no then I can't is is New York
pretty cut throat with all the comics
there or is it like yeah like nobody I
just love any time of day for them
anyone else they're just so so every
joke they have is one after the other I
love it yeah I love the pacing but also
I like a good pause between my J like I
like a good awkward pause to like let
them laugh at like me being awkward I
don't know but they got give any time
for like laughter they're just on tell
their well-written jokes well because
they they have to pay for open mics so
they like they got to like run through
them I guess their likes being the
silence because it makes people think
she had more time than she did yeah all
right cuz I don't write well it's like
uh it's like there's not a lot of time
and people write a lot and it's just I
like that style better yeah it does
almost though there's
a with like the inst clip and everything
now and like how many comedians there I
feel like not a lot of comics have like
more long
form like essay style like that I kind
of grew up on that I don't know maybe
that's just different when you're doing
hours you know yeah well you're seeing a
lot more of the shitty comics and then a
lot of the great Comics have hours out
too but they just get diluted yeah but
how many shitty Comics are but the
hourong style is still prevalent like
all the headliners do that yeah I guess
it's different when every set you do is
minimum 15 minutes versus minimum 3
minutes you know or less yeah it just
forc you to write different stuff that's
what I miss about like the New England
scene is everyone was writing new stuff
all the [__] time and it was so
inspiring but now here I get stuck in my
same old jokes yeah also in New England
like people had like five minute bits
yeah yeah cuz Dan was saying that oh
[__] you dude why did you build so many
roads you knew what I was was going for
you cut me
off I going for across the board all
right but longest road doesn't get you
more resources no it doesn't that's why
I [__] have been sucking this game
six all right I'm going to
build another
city I guess I'll do it right here and
eventually that robber will
move all right go
[Applause]
ahead
11 oh [__] yeah dude stepen Wright does
have amazing timing you're right about
that Christopher
Casto it's all but
like I met Steven Wright one
time yeah he's in Boston right yeah and
I was like I'm a comedian too too and he
was like keep doing it he said 85% of
everything he's ever
written uh never worked but that 15%
will get you
there
so that was just for me but I shared it
with you 16
people you done yeah and everyone else
I've ever
met 10 New England was so Aly too though
looking back oh so
Alf yeah on M I loved Studio manness I
did um I did my this is going to be only
to you two but I did my Jack Stoke at
Lucky Duck for the first time in a year
Jack my Jack and Mikey bigs is like I
loved it and they bombed so
hard eight eight all
right
I'm going to trade in for rock for a
wheat man it's windy
outside so
ominous so there was like a showcase at
Vulcan
today I didn't go but you mean the mic
they have an open 11 where's my
phone
[__] is Vulcan like gonna keep doing
comedy long term or yeah I went to an
open mic there the other night and
nobody was there and I just left it was
like all door guys the open mics there
have never worked
yeah Tom Tom we all started in New
England
like between 2 and 1 half 3 years ago
yeah I started uh
2019 2018 end of 2018 for me yeah I
started February 2019 yeah and then did
it exactly a year and then the pandemic
hit and then I had to take off a whole
year
six so technically I thought you started
in 2019 20 18 does no I started later
than does anyone have a a brick they
want to trade for a wood nope how about
two wood I don't have any cards I'll
give you a sheep I'm going to oh wait
what was just R uh six oh I'm going to
trade in uh for what did you wood for uh
brick and I'm going to trade and then
build another road I forget what I
rolled does anyone remember what I
rolled I think I got a eight
nine you got should play spin the bottle
if you didn't already hear we've
literally all kissed each
other I haven't kissed and I found my
mother dead anyone want weat and he
found his mother dead guys Patrick's mom
is dead what do you want for the wheat
brick no thank you what about sheep for
Brick anybody anybody or rock for a
brick Rock for Brick yeah no thank you
what about sheep you want wheat I'll
take a rock and a wheat for a
brick
um I can give you two wheat for one
brick or one wheat for one
sheep anyone have sheep and want wheat
how about two wheat for a
sheep
okay
do you guys think like New York and LA
are going to shut down again New York
already shut down did it at least for a
week the week of Christmas like every
bar there shut down because of omnicron
yeah I mean it did spread like [__]
wild there's going to be another surge
of comedians in Austin if those sit
cities like fully shut down again what
did you get six oh my god
dude for getting all right you can go
wait
yeah
11 that was a bluff she's bluffing she
has victory points she looked at them as
if they were Knights but she's bluffing
she has victory points I know
it to I mean I think David is it
possible to hurt a comedian here's the
thing comedians comedians are the most
sensitive babies on the planet all you
have to do is Judge one of their jokes
not even you can make fun of anything
about them but once you make fun of
their jokes they're like don't [__]
but also like comedians are like oh
nothing offends me but everything we're
so sens aren't we like isn't everyone
such babies that's why they're so good
at observing the world they feel
everything eight yeah I got on a
plus-size show and I cried we all became
comedians cuz people hurt our feelings
too much yeah we're like I want a way to
make I want to be a professional offense
to be I want to be a professional being
offended that is pretty much like a lot
of the time makes a comedian as being
made fun of and bullied and [__] I like
that comment of just Red
Band he's here he's
sleeping he's homeless literally are
[__] him we [__]
him I'm going to trade in eight wood for
a sheep and a brick and then I'm going
to build a
settlement this is the most expensive
settlement I know I
just and you also destroyed Katan to
build it I did Katan
no recreationally offended or in some
case professionally
nine can we stop rolling numbers I don't
have we'll try no it is like comedians
will do a like will tell a joke for
years perfectly crafting the opinion be
like oh it's just a joke like yeah but
like you've perfectly sculpted this this
thought and like are people starting to
call you herpes Hans that's adorable it
makes sense it's from the beginning I
probably I feel like I got from the
beginning yeah before I started kissing
people they called me in middle school I
was
like I wish
five brick in
a you give me a brick [__] me oh
Sor um does anybody have any wood nope
any
Rock I just saw your cards you have wood
me yeah not to trade oh Patrick [__] off
I have them shut up does anyone have any
brick I have wood you have Rock no
okay all right
I'm really just accepting this Los six
as soon as I realized we were recording
I didn't know we were recording this
until I got here and as soon as I
realized it I was like oh I'm going to
lose and some [__] women if we
weren't recording it yeah that's you'd
be crushing if we weren recording that's
what it is yeah know
yep hey people in the chat go watch
living with a sped on YouTube come back
plugg I made a I made a four season
series and it's pretty good go watch it
living with his
bed come back and be like that show
sucked that last
episode it's actually really good it's
actually a really good show I recommend
the silent episode it's called Uh living
in
silence none of none of
none of
[Laughter]
them all right never mind Patrick um
your mom is
dead it's
true three no three three I got three
all day God no one's run rolled to seven
in eight years I know you and I feel the
pain yeah one God oh
sorry F doesn't need those roads
[Applause]
eight there you
go
five
um does anybody have a
rock living with a living with a sped is
the show living with they're saying
living with Asbergers keeps popping Auto
Philly does anybody
have rocks living with Asbergers is just
a lot of stuff for two
rocks that no reason why do you have
bricks I just want to yeah can I have
two brick for one rock no
okay come on man actually you know
what
yeah and then I'm going to trade
in four sheep for a
[Music]
rock and then I'm going to build a
city where am I going to build it o hea
yeah you're doing bad I didn't know that
what I said you're doing bad yeah I'm
doing [__] horrible
I should have gone for that
Port but I listen to Hans that's the
thing oops if he [__] you over early I
told you didn't I wanted to build over
there six again huh you told me
to Heather do you want a wood for a
wheat or anything for a
wheat
if you give me three rocks P Patrick
they're trying to figure out how to find
your show living with a sped I think
you're they're probably spelling living
wrong l i v i n yeah you guys were
spelling it correctly I'm
sure and you can follow me on
Instagram plug
it search uh living with a sped Roid
Rage and then an episode will pop up and
then you can find the channel from there
I
um did I already go am I done yeah I
rolled a six oh does anybody have
wheat
yes what do you want for wheat not
multiple things give me give me wood one
wood give me two wood no I can't fine I
don't get [__] I'm
losing anybody else have
wheat I'll give you brick for
wheat brick for wheat anybody you want a
brick for a wheat no
okay come on you're
losing but that's not going to do
anything for me it'll give you a brick
stop thinking about yourself he winning
don't give it wait how many points does
he have he has 1 2 3 4 five six seven
[__] I didn't even know I was wining
four five wait two three four five six
oh I'm behind you nah I'm
good so what does the mic scene like is
there like a lot of new people coming in
all the time kind of I feel like I go to
Mike sometimes and I'm like how do I
know zero people here yeah like it's
weird I haven't felt that in a minute
but yeah I don't know it's I feel like
the mics are getting worse in Austin I
maybe I feel like cuz me and Patrick
have a mic at Creek and I uh I don't
really I don't know do you see new
people I feel like whenever there's new
people it's just people from Houston one
or two every now and again yeah but no
like regular new people yeah I guess if
someone you start seeing someone regular
eventually but also sometimes our mic
sucks just because it's right before
kill Tony so everyone leaves for Kil
Tony two three four five six yeah come
to the mom and popop open mic at 6:00 at
the creek in the cave on Monday 5:30
sign up every Monday don't sign up just
come to
watch unless you're a comedian sign up
sure does anybody have a
wheat no yeah you have enough for you to
trade yeah you got
Stone I
don't I have anything else I'll give you
a brick and a sheep done with this one
yeah I'll do that working a sheep for a
week I saw
vodka all right I'm going to build a
city can you put this on the
108 108 I never saw a
108 Chris Nolan's 10 um I didn't get it
1 two three I fake laughed at it you
caught me um no the mics I feel I don't
know there's a ton of mics in Austin now
done yeah yeah I'm all set but like you
know somewhere I don't know I feel like
when I got here a year ago there was
like there was nothing to do all you
know things were still like shut down so
like Lucky Duck was like not just the
only comedy thing it was just the only
thing to do in town I think like before
the everyone started coming like the
shows there weren't there aren't as many
mics but they were better yeah that SS
to happen I I went to New
Orleans and um they only had like One
mic a night but they were all great and
like there just like weren't very many
shows
that tends to happen I just miss how
good like Lucky Duck was and when um
when Joyce had that mic at um Blind Pig
cuz I loved using blind pig to like work
on my crowd work and that I loved that
space for it but Shakespeare's is just
sad yeah just sad and it's only comedian
so it's like what's the point of doing
crowd there's a giant beam right in
front of you you just blocks you from
the crowd you have to stand off the
stage does anyone want have wood
I don't this is a great premise cuz we
get on a idea and a good conversation
and then someone interrupts it with the
game wait what was just rolled am I uh
oh 10 10 oh I knew that I mean I I think
like Blind Pig was
unsustainable yeah but I like people
were getting pissed off during though
like when kill Tony was still it was so
[__] adversarial cuz people would
just be like yelling at each other but
if you seen now how many people go there
on the uh on the music nights it's
insane CU Shakespeare is right across
the street so we can literally see from
our shitty Open Mic how [__] how many
people are over there and it's so
sad yeah they're doing so much better
it's like watching your ex [__] a bunch
of
people yeah anyone wanted W though too
you're like she wasn't wrong what for
ra no she was like I just
need wood for rock uh I'll trade wood
for rock uh too late no whatever it
doesn't matter I'll do on my turn roll I
rolled a six but roll no no it wasn't
your turn roll were you done Hans um I
guess
not would for rock yeah thanks you want
to do it again no that was the only one
I had no Rogan does not have his shop
set up yet his shop haven't we all been
waiting for comedy that's why we all
moved here you that's not why I moved
here
no here because my friends were here and
I was like I'm sick of living in
Colorado then I got here and everyone
was like oh everyone's following Joe
Rogan I was like I didn't [__] know
that you're following the people that
you're following the people that
follow I went to college here and then I
was like I sick I roll a six I moved
here cuz I heard Red Man mov oh my God
I'm so
sorry oh what how does that even happen
dude [__] dude you're too strong I know
how a menace what the [__] no I'm just
clumsy my turn no well you're laughing
[__] no does anyone want to trade me
in Brick for a
wheat
yeah wait how many points do you have
wait well Pat two one wait two three
four five six seven eight no I'll trade
with Zach all right he's gonna build the
longest road and take my points wait but
how many points do you have 1 2 3 four 5
six and get longest
road you know
what you know
what give me two bricks I don't want to
wheat that bad I definitely don't want
to weat that
bad I'm GNA trade in four weeks you how
do you actually so [__] hate you guys
how do you think like do you think
there's going to be another surge of
people moving here when Rogan officially
announces yeah wait wait wait but like
people who are actually good at
comedy it's going to be like more I
don't play my night like professional
going move over here
and is he going to call it Joe's I
should have waited [__] Joe's joke heard
Joe he's going to call his uh I heard
he's going to call it
shorts what was I asking for a wood or a
brick cuz he's short I was asking for is
short asking for Brick you heard it here
first can you guys answer me what's up
was I asking you guys for Brick yes okay
I'm taking them back and I played my
night and I put it on
that let me steal room back did you buy
something huh I did but I took it
back can
see Jesus you're B sorry oh oh oh she
was so close [__] she was so close you
had it at first does anybody have a
rock I don't I'll literally trade you a
brick for that
sheep wow okay I didn't want yeah say it
was a good move in the end fun all right
now I buy a road
all
right
three interesting three this is
sponsored by
Oreos anybody have a wheat no anybody
have a wheat yeah you want I'll take a
rock I don't have a rock yes I literally
can see your cars what about two
sheep I'll give you a brick and a sheep
no I'm good thank you I can't read you
ever get give two brick for no I'm
good for this do you get paid for this a
little bit a little bit Yeah do we get
a little a quarter of a little bit I
thought I was just hanging out with my
friend now I'm getting recorded and paid
no I'm just kidding you just like when I
used to hang out with my
uncle by the way to be like this sucks
you're watching it you should turn it
off I've been watching this for an hour
and 20 minutes it's so depressing you
guys are losers yeah
that's what I like to do is put on a
stream and then insult anyone that
happens to stop by yeah I'm I'm so
dyslexic I thought I thought that said
everyone is moving to LA because of
Scrubs I was like is that so what like a
reboot oh sh it's a great show shrub is
good sh Brandon sha say what we will
seven great comedian God damn it one two
three four five six did you guys watch
Brendon sh
special we're all big Brendan
sha I'm here for alen sh every Brendan
sha fan is Big they're all jacked too
much swearing such a great fan base I
have a limited vocabulary I would
appreciate it if you didn't say that to
me yeah that's pretty sexist dude yeah
honestly yeah too much about
mansplaining
language
all right Patrick give me give me your
card finally the six is
free and then I'll buy a
settlement I've had I've had three on
did you best spell dyslexic or am I
dyslexic
I watched a clip of I I never actually
seen Brandon sh's special but I saw a
clip of um him making fun of uh in his
special of a like a doctor in the UFC
and he does like a really racist Asian
accent and then it cuts to the actual
doctor and he's like a perfect American
accent like he has no accent at all and
then it cuts to Brendan sha talking
about Shan Gillis being like that [__]
wasn't funny what he said wasn't funny
at all how dare he anyone want Bricker
wood for rock cuz that's a real thing
that happen no wait brick or wait what
oh
Nock that's
most most comi pay most Comics are just
t-shirt salesman that's actually what
they do three four five six
seven all right Genevie was selling
shirts at barrels and amps the other day
good for her she has some good shirts I
almost bought one but I am poor seven
one two
three yikes
almighty
um does anybody have a rock they want to
trade me give me give me give me give
me I'll give you wheat I'll give you
give you brick I'll give you sheep no
give
please give me can I please you want a
rock yes I want a rock I don't have it
God damn
it um thanks Tom Nook I want to buy a
development card I guess wait should I
do that she said I uh wait what did i i
r I came here hang out with friends and
I ended up being recorded and paid and I
said it's just like when I hang
ah and then I'm going to steal thanks
for I'm going to steal from you you can
see what I have that's unfair I only see
your brick dip [__] I don't even need
hey let's not let's not [__] on
comedians here 100 no they make fun of
Brendan
shop it's not
okay don't make fun of people that make
fun of other people I know that's really
class classless otherwise our society
falls apart no [__] way
okay I'm going to build a [__] City
idiots oh wow now you have four points
shut up six she's got the wait seven I
have seven oh yeah I forgot about your
[__] Army wait I should build it
there yeah this is a tight game yeah um
wait one second does
anybody anybody have any wood they want
to trade
me for rock for um I'll give you I
have I have wheat I have sheep and I
have brick anybody have wood they want
to give
me anybody have any [__] wood two
sheep for one wood I only have one sheep
okay all right I'll give you a wood for
wheat wood for wheat two wheat for a
wood I'll give you one wheat for one
wood only what I have huh it's the only
one I have I genuinely need it it's a
shitty trade two wheat for one
wood don't you think like you have to be
an introvert to be good at
comedy kind of you have to be really
just reflective of and that's that
sensitivity made me like less of an
introvert
it's better to go from an introvert
to uh an extrovert than an extrovert to
an introvert cuz it's harder to
be uh in your own head and thinking
seven seven yeah you're smarter it's
easier to go from smarter to dumber than
Dumber To smarter I mean I I definitely
think you you have to be it's not a it's
not a team sport you know it's like it
has to be totally you and that I don't
think happens
when
you're just super
extroverted see from him he's winning he
has one card it doesn't matter he's his
cards are all on here it might be the
card you want to
Brick he's
lying all right I'm all set if you're
funny David I don't think being
introverted makes you good at
comedy no I think introverts like spend
a lot of time with their thoughts and
they make themselves crack up nine so oh
nice four
wheat um should have put it
there all right did you say that
already 10 sad we can't
10 ah Bill Hicks
sucks it's literally his favorite
comedian my dad got me a bill hick shirt
for
Christmas I was like why'd you get me a
shirt of this guy who
sucks wasn't funny at all I think
comedy's made me about a thousand times
more
confrontational confrontational
definitely well just like I'm just way
better at just like wait what year old
uh 10 right yeah like I never once
brought anything up to anyone but now I
like I don't know I've had like problems
with like roommates before and now I'm
like I feel very comfortable being like
hey wash the dishes what' you roll H he
red his
10 God damn it dude what' you roll
11 does anybody have a wheat or a rock
they want to trade me yeah what do you
got I have a sheep I'll do a sheep for a
wheat for a wheat yeah okay anybody have
a rock they want to trade me for a
sheep I have a sheep no I have
sheep anybody have a
rock all right then [__] go God damn
it who are the local Club Heroes three
Casey rocket Casey rocket dude he just
got here D I saw him I saw him
Bomb by the way but I saw him confuse a
crowd like crazy the other night and I
was like why aren't they eating this
up it genuinely confused me I was like
because you're not for everybody yeah
that crowd was weird they were like
we're here it was at persing persing the
thing that Dan pesy does one love that
thing oh really that's yeah typically a
good crowd yeah it was a good crowd and
shooting a street over what a fun
night so Texas so Texas anybody have a
rock I'll give you brick um Jason my two
bricks for a rock my worst roommate
experience is not a funny story it's
just I lived with three friends and two
of them just had a to falling out over
the course of a year and we just scream
at each other all the time and I would
just stay in my room like this is like
my parents divorce again I have aak but
now I would just yell at them no I don't
have a
you stole my only
rock you a brick for a rock a brick I
don't have any
Rock I have to
pee is it okay I've got time this is an
awkward thank you I'm going to trade in
three wait
it's I think
it's they're talking about like cracking
jokes to customers and public speaking
versus comedy I think like like I've
always been pretty good at public
speaking but like when you start comedy
like everyone's bad when they start even
if they're like funny naturally in
conversation I don't know like these
these I feel like everyone like all of a
sudden it's totally it takes so long
just to like feel like yourself up there
yeah it's so weird social situation it
yeah and most people aren't used to it
man it takes a while to get used to like
everyone listening to you yeah um and
like having everyone pay attention cuz
usually like when you're talking people
are like oh that's just one guy we can
ignore him if he says something stupid
but then if you're up there and you say
something stupid they're like oh well we
can't ignore it so we have to
internalize everything which is good if
you're like a nerd and you have never
been heard before but it's bad if like
you have some weird beliefs yeah do you
think that's like a power trip for like
introverted people that like have never
had that before cuz I feel like that's
kind of a thing a lot of comics go to
includ I don't know including myself of
just like all of a sudden like now you
have getting more
arrogant yeah we put this the 10 going
towards the yeah um but I think like
it's not their fault I think like a lot
of our conversation and our uh relating
to each other [__] yeah I agree it's
dude I've had an 11 this whole [__]
time yeah I've never picked up on 11
there's been so many 11s roll I didn't
even know that all right oh my oh
my
now I'm going to buy the most expensive
uh City and trade in eight wood for two
Stone and then build a city
oops what did you roll uh an 11 okay I
rolled a
three
good you rolled a three yeah oh [__]
dude
oh anyone want brick or wood for
rock no have a
rock uh I'll do a wood for a rock how
many people are watching now do you want
to do do it again
no it's Katan Settlers of
Katan and where are you guys watching
from Williams sleeping in the back
room with red
band
okay um
does anybody have Rock they want to
trade for a
sheep or a hay you want to you want to
trade me a sheep for a hay or a rock you
want a sheep for a hay I have a sheep
I'll take I'll give you a rock
fory no for the hay for the hay no I
giving a sheep for wheat huh you said
you wanted a rock no I want I'm going to
give you a sheep but I want a hay or
Rock oh okay now I don't have a weat or
a rock H you notice a big difference in
style between I mean we talked about
like the fast-paced New York Style
versus like Seattle and
Austin yeah there's a little difference
I think like most of the time it's just
people are uh uniquely themselves so I
think the city has an impact but I think
it's mostly just who you are and people
are so unique and different and it's
cool to see that shine through no matter
what city they're in that is my favorite
thing about comedy it's like my favorite
way to like learn about groups you know
like like different like hey Hans where
in Massachusetts which city has the
biggest
wieners um New York really yeah I feel
like New York is just like really uh
special uh favoritism based and it
doesn't really select for talent like
the only thing New York has going for it
is that everyone wants to move there and
then they squander that head head start
and that Advantage well I like I feel
like everyone pays attention to the
writing there which is nice yeah cuz
like everywhere I've done comedy it's
just like oh that was funny if you tell
like a dick joke or a fart joke they're
like that was [__] funny but if you
do like a Wellcraft they think with
their animal parts there was a couple I
got a couple people in New York say to
me the writing was really good and I was
like oh okay you really paid attention
then yeah it's like what they choose to
emphasize who wants to give me wheat no
sheep I don't have wheat I'm not on any
Wheat ports my weakness and I think La
is more like act out based yeah I've
notic that from the comics that move
here you can go from La yeah we all
watched Theo
special but I like La better in some
ways they're more like open to new ideas
I've never been to
La I don't think anyone's good at comedy
comedy's terrible dude when you really
think about it nobody is
funny South
warer Massachusetts baby nice dude yeah
we in Massachusetts south central
Worcester say the town [__] wer wer
wer sorry about the swearinger you we're
allowed to South Central
Worcester like Wester County I lived in
New Hampshire and I loved
it oh yeah everyone I I almost moved to
Worcester before I moved to Worchester
Worchester
werer I almost moved to wer why you
spell it like
that sauce before I moved to Austin can
you but I gave up on that what are you
doing all right I'm all set oh I guess
that makes
sense I built the one cuz yeah I was
going to build something there but nine
[__] off with these
nines okay so much wheat for that I know
I got a Charlton
charlon the
road going to trade in for
wheat two three four five build another
Road H say 5 2
six does anyone have a a brick wait did
does Patrick still have longest road or
no no no P you do
two 1 2 3 4 5 6 seven
eight seven eight also Zach's
leite and he's about to win no I'm not
yeah
yeah build the settlement just building
a
settlement
goe 12 is anyone on a 12 oh
yeah 12 all
right he just won the game oh yeah cuz
we're all on the board or I mean we're
on every single
[__] damn we're on every single we
did it guys we settled Katan
Heather I don't know if it's
statistically possible for you to win no
I don't know matically you'd be
surprised oh you got some points baby oh
I don't know maybe I have a night anyone
want wood for
Brick no hottest celebrity I love Ross
Lynch is that gay to say n dude Ross
Lynch four I don't know what it is I
love little white boys him as Jeffrey D
Jeffrey dmer I was like wait actually
Jeffrey dmer wasn't that bad no he was
attractive he was fine he was a sexy
teenage boy apparently an Frank do you
know Anne Frank wasn't a
virgin they found like a page in the
back of like his her dad found a page in
the back of her diary that was like
sealed off and she wrote in detail about
her boyfriend before hiding that she
like [__] she was a filthy [__] she
was a [__] [__] dude and her dad
ruined the book by ripping that page out
yeah
seven okay um wait what are you guys on
I need a I need a [__] wheat steal
from Zach I wouldn't yeah I'm going to
steal from
Zach I'm going to steal I'm wait I'm
going to wait I'm going to put it right
here and then I'm going to steal from
you that's silly give me give me give
that 12 was a great spot that's a
hard he's literally about to win that 12
is up what are you talking about all
cover the nine if you're going to cover
anything should have covered the nine
three it's not too late go back and then
I'm going to put down these rocks and
then I'm going to build this right wait
2 4 6
78 I'm [__] getting there I'm getting
there kid one two three four five
six
11 she for me
mantis can skinny guys be attractive oh
can they Timothy sh shom no I'm orando
Bloom that's the same guy isn't that the
same
guy Brad Pit's pretty skinny bed pin
Fight Club was so skinny dude he was
like [__] he kind of ripped he was
but he wasat in Seven Years in Tibet he
was skinnier anybody you guys like that
yeah I have wheat you got
Stone I got a little drunk do two stone
for a wheat I don't don't trade with
Zach why are you trading with Zach
again I'm not going to do it take take
it back take it back I take it back you
can't do
that Frank out of this and Frank is in
every [__] conversation I ever
[__] have don't ever ask that's right
David pit was SK what are you
anti-semitic what are you what you never
want me to talk about the most important
Jew what did I say I said Put it on the
12 he didn't put it on the 12 and Zach
just won the game because of no I'm
going win I would have won if you did
that trade no wait did he roll a [__] I
told you wanted to [__] want Tock I'm
not going to win I'm not going to win
but I am going to get a stone mantis are
you vaccinated and just
don't I didn't see the episode who was
the guy was it what was
his nine okay this guy said even her
notes were hiding that's [__]
hilarious do you do
comedy do you
[__] I got drunk you
guys anyone want this for wood no no
what about this for
no what about FR wheat or how much wait
what do you need brick or wheat no I
don't have any or
sheep say that for sheep yeah give me
two things for a
sheep you're telling me a guy named
muko M I can't read your name I'm
kidding Zach has nine I'm not good and
you have
nine you don't know that I kind of do
thank
you my last name is Silverman so you
know you can infer yeah there's a Jew
here wait
okay give me give me give me I'm last
hurts feels
bad
10 are your um fans antivaxers Hans
yeah they're all from Kill Tony yeah
that makes
sense 10 oh
[__] does anybody have a wheat or a
brick they want to trade me no I've got
lot has too many rocks give me give me
give me give me give me give me
something give me a wheat or a brick no
pleas okay does anyone have a KN a weed
or a brick a KN if you have a night you
should steal and try to take if you have
a night you should steal and try to get
his I don't get his Rock it's because
Zach's about to win yeah he has three
rocks it's also because Hans is going to
win right after Zach I
don't yeah you have nine you have nine
all right I'm going to trade this is a
tight game you want this yeah for a
sheep yeah sure okay sick and then I'm
going to
trade I'm going to trade win Heather no
I don't think so oh [__] me no I can't
she possi [__] I just [__] up wait do
you want that for a wood you want to
trade me back for a wood uh a sheep
sure you're giving me another wood we
just traded two Woods together oh what
the [__] wait no I want that she back
Bri oh that's what I was saying wait for
that sheep back wait did you I'm getting
my uh I have a appointment to get my
booster Monday [__] okay why are you
guys so obsessed with men's weight we're
supposed to be obsessed with women's
weight in this country it's just what
they're thinking
about I mean men do we have to be big
anymore because we're in a modern era
where we don't have to beat each other
you what you go please if I don't have
to be big that's all I got
that's
eight eight yeah someone steal from Zach
or he's going to
win um oh David you've been
complimenting the men all night you
you're probably that's fair you
can you want to have a conversation with
us yeah I'm talking talking to the
lovely
viewers I'm not going to listen to a
podcast what am I
loser n i just Kidd what kind of what
kind of podcast do you guys listen to
recommend me no one no one can steal
from Zach it'll be
impossible cuz even if I bought a thing
I couldn't use
it this feels very weird that I'm
getting recorded I don't like it I
didn't agree to this it's too late
literally zero consent on my part it's
been happening I saw the cameras and I
went what what are we going to record
this and they went yeah and I went
anybody have a Wii no Z you well you did
actually pretty good for the spot you
were in what cuz we kind of let you
catch
up like we've been dilly dally oh
spoiled the beans nice that's um D post
and Sam lope right oh oh is it yeah is
it I love them they're so cute they
posted a they posted like a New Year's
thing of them on stage and them kissing
like on stage with like sparklers going
off I was like both good at comedy
yeah an LA couple derck poen once called
me a killer and I was like oh yeah he's
so
good he's so nice I love yeah I love
them both together they're so
cute what are you going to do are you
winning not at all Zach is about to win
I'm just holding it off as long as I can
yeah
three four five six seven eight
nine me put this over there are you
saying I look good on
camera I literally need to shave my
mustache but thank
you good for you Zach it was a fun game
three I win you [__] [__] did you
really yeah I can buy a a city and that
gives me 10 good game good game did you
have a Victory Point yes so you had nine
points I had nine points I had nine
points you have six seven eight points
that's a good game it's 10 to n to 9 to
eight I went for that longest road in
the beginning like an idiot and it
ruined my game should we play again you
should never I will literally play I
would literally play again rematch do
you really want to I
would here I would yeah no
play I love G
don't
rematch if five people say
rematch rematch Hans loses again I swear
to God we will do you lose on your do
you lose I won yesterday [__] Hans
wins all the time Hans and Patrick
always [__] win it's annoying that
could literally not be the case that's
impossible I was for how [__] shitty
my spots were I'm surprised how close I
was to winon I won six games in a row is
this the victory point you got a [__]
Market that's good that's a good victory
you're capitalist undress you guys want
to get naked no
yeah play video you can see me shirtless
on kill Tony David's a great David's a
very nice guy yeah play video games
no this isn't twitch
dude what do you just hang out for a
little bit after someone
wins yeah I mean you want to Gareth is
calling what's up Gareth you're on call
with the whole group yeah are you or
down south South no I'm at the place you
were at yesterday say the address
rematch rematch all right we need four
more people to say rematch bring snack
I'll see you soon who else are you there
with bring me Doritos dude [__] bring
snack let me try to get him to bring
another person so we can have six yall
play Risk you need six to do
the
no else me espe not temp okay but if
there is you should try to bring one
along so we have
six I will try to entice my
friends actually we're good yeah just
come alone we'll see you well [__] you
dude my friends are fun you yeah don't
bring that kid who always gets so close
to my face what's his name Antonio don't
bring Antonio don't bring that [__]
that's your Al of r
That's The Witcher that was The
Witcher so let's uh put down put up the
six player board all right let's do it
okay are we staying on the SL bringing
another person sure whatever I mean he
said that he might but well that other
person turned out to be Derek diol which
makes Gareth showing up way
worse that's like super
Gareth double autism we'll triple with
h yeah yeah yeah not us just them
yeah most of us are f i lit I literally
was telling you a story today about how
my mom sat me down and told me to make
more eye contact my my dad thought I was
autistic that's hilarious and didn't
listen
to not looking at people okay but also I
was 15 when she did that that's way too
late like the ship is sail that was a
sophomore in high school this is a this
is going to be a lifetime full Us
staring at
clavicles it is so weird that you have
fans H I know it hasn't really sunk in
yet yeah I remember like seeing you at
open mics just in the corner with your
mask and your longboard
yeah um that sounds about right it was
adorable now you now you never go to
open now you kiss hot [__] and do
this me and Hans met in the basement of
the creek in New York at the beginning
of
2020 I don't remember that I don't
remember it either but when you got here
I was like I recognized him and then I
saw your van and I remember your van I
remember talking to you at Creek and
then seeing you move your van afterwards
my white van yeah nice
so must have been later on into my
tenure yeah it was at the beginning of
2020 that actually would be funny
someone's saying that it would be fun if
we ate hot wings and playing goodan hard
C ask hot questions and hotter wings no
just we're all just playing Katan
going that's so that's so
good do you have any
milk so stupid there's sauce on
everything yeah just ruins the
board no
truly I came here to hang out with my
friends now I'm being recorded paid and
I'm sweating breathing heavy what is
this wait are we actually playing again
yeah yeah we're waiting for Gareth
though oh yeah is he on his way yeah how
far away is he
uh stick to Blue how many people are
watching
now don't worry about it don't [__]
worry about it dude let's get that
number higher I just hope none of our
friends are watching this cuz I get a
weird podcast voice when I do [__] like
this um [__]
listeners welcome to friends
play Hans kind have another beer I get
two in my head about being reported we
are coming to you live from Austin Texas
that's literally my ZIP code our ZIP
code what do you why are you wasting
matches dude for the
smell I love the smell matches we have
like we don't have a lighter here so the
only way to light things is with matches
and we only have like four matches left
now I like smoking cigarettes with
lighting a cigarette with a mat I love a
cigarette right now the best can we
smoke in his smoke in the Pao is Rachel
cool be gone ID the smell will be gone
by the time she gets
back what are people saying if you ask
questions about Hans we'll give you the
embarrassing
details it's true ask how big his penis
is only Patrick knows that but and it's
not
embarrassing
just tell me
when ew what is it's a pocket
cigarette don't smoke it in here idiot
yeah smoke it outside you have you have
a lighter don't smok it and it's C
where's she going to SM when she going
to be here smoking outside you when she
coming
back be gone I have do really badly with
smoke all right my little brother's
watching this I can't is he really no I
don't know is Dylan on me hi
Dy
sorry did you guys Chad his name is not
that bleep that out
H I won't be related to no
Dylan I just keep sniffing into the
microphone I think it's hilarious but I
don't think anyone likes it but me do
you want to listen to yourself yeah wait
I actually hate my voice but want to do
it oh that's so that is the worst when
you hear your voice back and you're like
that's what I [__] sound like sound
like a someone cre
child I'm so dyslexic I can't is there
another set of headphones I want to hear
no have you guys been hearing me just
gulping and bur burping yeah can you
hear the gulping I keep turning way to
swallow like that's what she said I just
sculped but it's like it's it's my
throat so yeah I hear it Hans van smells
like kimchi and ribs I love all your
noise and whes dude David you're so
horny dude
tomorrow relax we know Timothy shallows
lb they are free at the gas station that
is true
is my voice soothing do you like guys
like
ASMR don't you guys think they should
allow me to smoke that cigarette
inside we're going to play good we're
going to play We Get Enough votes for me
to smoke the cigarette inside I'm going
to do it don't do it Patrick this is why
your mom killed herself yeah just go
outside Heather can do an ASMR
porn podcast you hate ASMR I hate it
D this ASMR it goes out to what are you
Dave Chappelle this goes out all the
haters death and
destruction your children will never
grow old e have you heard Michael Ian
Black's uh joke about banana
noises he does a joke where he goes I
get on an airplane and I just go
[Laughter]
and sometimes I hit them with the
double it's so [__] funny he's one of
my favorites yeah thats
better don't [__] he's so underrated
he was like go outside dude take Zach
with you have you um have you guys
watched Burning Love Burning Man no
burning love you ever been to Burning
Man no that what Bernie
Sanders you ever been to Bernie
man my brand of cigarettes is maror Reds
yeah mine mine too oh wow you can really
hear me burping or American Spirit Blues
I can't smoke maror lights because my
mom used to smoke them on road trips and
it just gives me a headache
now I told someone today I was like I
was like yeah my mom used to smoke all
the time and I would go to school
smelling like cigarettes and I thought
it was the funniest story and they were
like oh that's
sad it gives her headaches because her
mother would smoke them and hit her in
the head yep oh okay give her my numbing
orgasm ASMR we didn't laugh loud enough
do you guys like that type of ASMR
ASMR okay so H do you [__] like this
[__] where are you going dude go out
this way there's a
thanks I do be burping that's the
[__] be burping [__] be burping
dude some [__] be shopping I be
burping it's fine when I was 13 I asked
to buy some cool six the guy asked what
kind I said Menthol that's that's fine I
don't judge that I
do cigarettes are for losers dude
American Spirits takes so [__] long
to to smoke they piss me off is this my
podcast now Hans is gone dude did you
guys hey there Keith reviews cigarettes
I do I do be reviewing cigarettes i' be
burping but I don't be shopping tell all
your
friends I don't know I don't know what
cools are put it to your mouth give me
more cigarette content I love
this I so miss smoking [__] pick it
back up [__] New Year's
resolution should I lock the door yeah I
would not just choose the good ones yeah
yeah that's what I say about drugs
too I was
13 Chad what's your favorite we were all
13 at one point you can't prove
thatf try Canadian
cigarettes oh no it's is M DeMarco
Canadian I feel like he
is oh is Gareth here we got we got
geralt of Rivier Rivia
here what's up dude set here dude we're
live on YouTube right here am I taking
Hansa seat or is that which one we're
going to get you a chair
okay dud D yeah no I literally cheated
the last game nobody noticed
but what the [__]
what the [__] that's so not cool
somebody you're such a [__] and you
still lost and still lost you loser no
every time somebody rolled a seven I
like no it was only once but somebody
rolled a seven and I had eight cards and
I just didn't say anything I did make a
face to the camera but nobody noticed
how did you get in who's Altoids there
the gate open I thought you did that
just planned it I'd be cheating at kitan
it's not that big of a deal and you know
what's always fun funny is like you can
pick up a card nobody
notices I
know but then that that but then I do
really feel good about winning yeah that
win would be Hollow no no I feel great
about winning always but you know okay
Jeffrey up can you guys see my mustache
I was going to Heather you're literally
Jeffrey
Epstein probably the best example
cheater you saw the faces cool I was
doing like an office thing like a what
an you like
that people are just hitting on Heather
now who else no they're literally not I
look like trash that's why I was like
you guys should have told me recording I
would have put on some [__] makeup
that there's makeup in the bathroom cool
hide yourself
cool I get organic organic the same what
you look the same I have really bad bags
under my eyes when I don't wear makeup I
look like I just got punched allerg
thank you Hans Hans is so [__] in
love with me are you hearing
this okay it's pretty obvious are you
guys dabbing I'm Miss dabbing I'm doing
dabs dude you want one yeah sure no I
can't handle it anymore I had a bad
shroom trip when I was like uh 17 and
now smoking weed just makes me
dissociate why do you have to be so
negative that's my [__] brand this
guy has an should kill Tony ticket if
anyone wants to go there and sit down no
way I'm down actually I'd rather not sit
i' I can I just say I kissed Hans before
kissing Hans was cool you were kissing
me when no one was kissing me so is that
cool or not I think it's hard is that
cool or
[Laughter]
sad [__] you what is are we live are we
actually we are live Gare this is Gareth
we're going to play another probably
told you that before you started
lighting up a [__] is that is that
all allow no it is go ahead I just
didn't know if you wanted your employer
to see it [__] uh this is cvd I like
hearing everything this is like this is
this is cvd I don't know what the word
meta means but I feel like this is
meta no YouTube's owned by Google this
is [__] meta's f it was a good joke
no it wasn't I'll K myself okay
welcome back to my as I had people at my
work find edited comedy recently I kept
it from them for a year and a half
that's cool and they found my
Instagram you know there was this guy
that I worked with and he was like oh I
do comedy too I can't read no you don't
I would see you everywhere never seen
you in my life man I was like what are
you [__] talking about Valentino but
I love him to death and uh he'll be back
eventually in the scene he did it for
like a month yeah he's like you don't
know what comedy is until you do it for
a month know you got to do it for a
month straight you know exactly what
comedy is he's like all right man I love
him to death though he's a cool cat I
guess I had a guy I went out with a
friend who she's in sales and um do it
for me okay a bunch of her have no idea
how to do any of them what the [__] is
that oh like that
um um but yeah there was one of the she
some of her co-workers there and I say
sales cuz sales guys are the worst
people on the planet just just the worst
scum I don't live in a van thanks for
asking I live in an apartment what's
wrong with living in a van shut the [__]
up there's everything wrong with living
in a van I can't piss in a bottle Hans
is thriving right now people are giving
him places to stay I have to pay [__]
$1,700 a month for R what the [__] where
do you live I live in a nice place okay
well shut up then G's doing
well I like where I live and I like work
and I do well I don't want to live in a
van because I'm a woman and I would get
raped hey hether lives in a shopping
cart GL live right now we can Rec our
story
together how was uh the cigarette it was
nice it was great wait did you finish it
I want you said ew you know it's a
[__] myth that so secondhand smoke
kills people that's so it is how is it
not if it's bad like why is does putting
in someone else's lung suddenly take out
all the it doesn't but you're not
getting any of the bad [__] from
secondhand smoke well you're getting a
little bit go watch p and teller's
[__] and you'll be like oh totally
no
it's shopping cart that's can I that
makes no the guys the famous doctors ped
and tellers
they're scientists actually and uh one
of them's a magician that would be like
taking medical laugh in the face of
Science and make a mockery of science
the people were like oh look this C is a
different C Now The Wiz all scientists
were is this at one point let's be real
um someone said nobody rapes Bridge
trolls buddy what world do you live
Patrick like
that nine
oh are we rolling trying to tell Heather
she's safe three
[__] uh I have a six-pack also my oh
12 I'm going last I'm
going that's the spot you want baby
we're making content how one looking at
the screen
five okay I got drunk so I feel like
this game is going to be more fun uh who
R the nine right off the that seven r a
12 no Patrick roll a 12 don't [__]
put that on me don't you put that don't
[__] that Bobby don't you put that
evil on me Ricky Bobby wa said how many
people are looking at this right now do
we have anyone watching wa can I also
have another video oh there's a little
chat right there Hi people hey since he
got here do you guys know why I said
don't invite
Gareth you son of a [__] don't think
that Gareth looks exactly like Chandler
Bing look at the camera he's basically
Chandler look the camera look at the
camera Chandler you look exactly like
Chandler Bing I don't I look like
generic white person
that I guess so dude a little more
original we've been over this you look
like him I'm not saying it as a
everybody [__] say you said a generic
white guy I said go with a better
[__] answer he's a generic white guy
it's a generic answer it's a generic
white guy answer what is uh who's the uh
Fox News guy Tucker Carlson you look
like you look like if Tucker
cars see that car Tucker Carlson and
ch right there right there a little baby
that's good yeah Gareth looks like
Hannah gas you can
see you can actually if you look close
enough you can see through me right now
you're transl like God I'm so [__]
white no you're like not white like I
feel like tan like you're actually the
white you're actually eggshell white
someone says you look like a soccer dad
that had a kid and life decision I
disagree I feel like Gareth looks like a
soccer dad that brings gushers to games
oh that's High Praise thank you so super
high PR I love you Heather and you're a
beautiful person feel Indi about you but
we're having fun can you straddle the
leg go Z wait like this yeah his name is
Gareth not Garrett [__] idiot [__]
get the name of our F got the name of
our town [__]
correct yeah it's actually how everyone
knows me here oh Gareth The Village The
Village
Idiot are you saying gareth's bringing
the diversity to this group like me and
Hans haven't been here the whole time
how has he
diverse a whoever said that I love you
though so thank you so because he's
Hannah Gatsby and that's what she does U
let's pick up GTH is like a mom to
me and that you just met him four
minutes ago I don't know I'm getting
[__] and then I [__] both of them
all right I have to pee before we go
wait oh did someone already who's going
Patrick went yeah yeah you're oh [__]
you can go no not yet I got to pee no
it's your turn take turn your turn get
Jesus look at that shot
dude I I don't want that got wait for
Heather that one's a little that is
heavy
[__] my
bad it is Tios yeah handmade vodka I do
have I have yeah I have a six-pack in
the car Austin's drank one of them
Austin Tito is an Austin brand oh is it
yeah I didn't know that yes yeah they
have they have a store they have a store
that just sells merch in the city it
doesn't sell vodka it just sells mer is
that so weird they have the yeti store
here to it's like imagine building a
store that's just an ad it's very like
Time Square of them they do it's very
Austin very much just a billboard of a
store um they're basically telling you
go online and buy it or whatever [__]
hate you guys that's so mean a PE bottle
a PE jar yeah I realize that you all
have the best [__] spots that you
know last game the score was 10 to9 to 9
to8 is this your water Zach was sitting
on nine for a
while but uh Zach won last time yeah he
didam it I almost drank that fun fact
I've never won a game of Katon not once
in my [__] whole life I'm like over
for like a 100 I swear to God you got to
pick the spot with the most dots I
understand the [__] I hate you so much I
don't know how you lose them I [__]
hate you here's good here's good one
time I was gonna win my friend cheated
that's why I hate Heather right now what
don't talk about remember your
friend I played with this friend and we
were playing for 3 hours and all he did
was build a road for 3 hours and I
started making fun of he built one road
his name in my phone is now Antonio one
road one road Antonio is it my turn no
it's my turn sorry can you til can you
til the screen a little bit I want want
to read the cams do want going to put it
up on the TV fix that piece of the I
like it right there you like it even
better I don't want to see myself that
big whatever wow someone get her a pea
bottle they said they like you oh do
they do you guys like Heather we miss
Heather what do you guys like the least
that's a good question yeah don't say me
you guys miss
myr the boring guy that is good at Katan
and ruins the game did someone just call
me thick dude I'm fing mid dude don't
[__] God damn it dude why do you hold
on to the mic stands like everyone keeps
calling Garrett or is that just auto
correct no it's probably one of the oh
my god oh okay that makes sense
actually I thought you did something
dumb Patrick's your least
favorite blue shirt guy oh my God name
tag I'm the girl you figure it out
figure out the girl name and that's
me why is Patrick your least
favorite Heather it's your turn oh it is
[__] I didn't even look at the board fat
punani tight and fast wow that's two
votes for me good job David I'll I got
to pee no one make fun of me oh I'm
god
um his head
isot but I don't know oh [__] I forgot
there's two deserts now you never know
what the [__] is going to happen with
this [__] Zach is like the hodar of
our group Hodor did you say that about
him hodar did you just say hodar I
[__] fake fan Garrett I like our
color scheme right now yellow green red
blue we look
like like toddlers in uh preschool in
taros
oh uh let me figure out where I'm going
stop distracting me what the [__] crazy
to be like let me have the best
preschooler
yeah it's a little bit much but it is
where our world is you know sexy
children I'm going to go I well if
you're going to you know if you're going
to have one might as well pick the
sexiest one wait am I going twice like
my kid's the most extreme kid give me
one second my dad's going to beat up
your dad it's like my kid's going to
[__] your kid my kid's the most rapable
everyone wants to rape my kid why did
this turn into this what happened right
fathers and Tiaras it's like how would
you want that for your kid if the priest
was going to rap child like a Canon
Gatorade [__] dude give me a second
Z okay we've come along R cast though
for
sure God damn
it okay I'm going to I'm going to [__]
up I always [__] up with where I choose
but I'm just going to go for it I don't
give a [__] wa look at her she's got
attitude I
try is that wait let me rethink this
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
no I didn't pick a [__] rock I'm an
idiot didn't pick a [__]
rock nothing else hey let's all do our
shots yeah oh yeah we have ran out I
need a clay and I don't get one are you
serious dude give me a little bit of
yours you owe me [__] off dude wait you
know what you owe me
for I put it your butt blow job dude I
put it in your butt dude are you kidding
me I keep picking the worst guy you have
like a teacup over there yeah it's
adorable that was more than a shot that
was like two shots dude it was it was a
lot good amount [__] clay
rock thank you thank you sir yeah
problem Heather can I please hit your
mango yeah you can it hell yeah baby
Zachary I like that I like the D and D
reference I like
that who's the who's
everyone oh that'll be way better oh
nice that covers me up right up that be
great oh yeah try to try to put the
camera or try to pull it back under the
camera if you can where's a we and a
rock cuz it's like you can see it hard
you can for sure what the [__] this
board sucks just push it over here push
it over here in front of the door cuz
you're like I already know that it's
like [__] in the way you're like for
sure it's 100 are you guys helping me
don't test this autism dude I literally
just cheated once don't [__] say that
bring a lot to this okay I cheated a one
round I'm not that big of a
cheater I cheated nine times the last
game nobody nobody [__]
cheating I came place [__]
I didn't I didn't cheat once and I won
that's Justice you guys can't even cheat
to win cuz you're a good person Z [__]
wait can't see
anything you're always Wing guys who in
the chat who's your favorite of the five
of us love why why is that your such
your concern like who's the favorite I
want to hear them say they love you
you're going to come in last of course I
am that's not the point though it's he's
always got talking a little bit to say
who has the best
hair me it's definitely not me it's
Heather it's Heather it's a tie between
me and Hans nonwhites have good hair
yeah it's not be racist shut the [__] up
H Patrick's your favorite that's cool
can everyone shut up while I figure out
my [__] you guys kind words only yeah H
Hans is totally balding dude am I yeah
he's the only one he the only one here
who's bding can hear in the not anyone
else can I have an
Oreo I
guess
s close she only has three sleeves left
for
herself are we doing this yeah let's do
it wait do I have oh you need to go tce
such a big shot wait did that just
Heather have you even gone once you need
go two stop I'm literally figuring out
I'll take a sip of it to oh my God wait
if I put it
and I just need I would just need brick
and a rock to the brick and The Rock to
K but that's [__] [__] off guys this
sucks but if I put it here I would only
that was a huge shot yeah is
that
yeah where well we're partying oh my
happy New Year everyone can't see I'm
having the worst time over here to yall
too I love you want to stand up or sit
down too saw you come in for the show
for a little but uh I did a little set
Vulcan or whatever yeah did a little set
is this still recording oh [__]
me is
this wait if I go sorry for bringing D
last night dude what was that that was
crazy he said he looked at me and I was
not drunk but I was
okay him tell
me I know I was an idiot and I do stupid
things sometimes and I apologize no I
mean I I should be more cool with Derek
but I'm just not it's it is what it is
man I understand yeah Derek
sucks we're talking about Derek poon
right yeah no no I like yeah no D post
and rules all right we can play
now now are we taking a shot we already
did we already oh what the we already
took it let's be more in the moment
Zach you didn't take your shot you [__]
no I pretend I you [__] okay good I
see two I to take your [__] shot for
you I literally just said give me your
cup I'm good you know even if we don't
do this live Kat again Hans like or if
we do this in the future just the
lighting I appreciate the lighting very
much on this board right now like I want
this on every game honestly it makes
things much easier yeah cuz you can't
see numbers dude why do you have bring
dude that's what Riley would do aka the
stupidest lamest guy ever he would
always like [__] it's too bright in
here we got to turn the lights down move
your head a little back it's not chill
The Vibes are off where is
he do you know do you think it's more
interesting to
like ask what people
are guys where is Riley the game just
someone said this game will never end it
just [__] started hey you know have
you ever play guon dude whoever you are
it's a it's a takes time it's a [__]
process PE size M I'm going to look up
who m is do you guys so lost in the chat
he lives on inter I do can't not look at
the chat it's crazy what the that's most
interesting I've never interacted with
who cares also still it's not I agree
with that dude right now whoever needs
to [__] go needs to go whose turn is
it Patrick's turn I [__] win oh it's
my turn it's what a weird looking guy oh
this literally a week older than turn
this is in the
way I'll put it back in
later I'm not
connected this feels weird now good
night
underscore thanks for staying this long
love you were a nice
viewer 5
7 9 10 11 go follow follow uh Packer
deari on Instagram no watch my last uh
watch my last clip I did comedy on 8
tabs of acid can I actually I want the
head tabs
ofd I feel weird now that it's called
promoting figure it out bro plug plug in
your [__] sorry you don't have any Clips
to post sorry you record every set for
the last 3 years and you haven't shut
your [__] mouth oh my God okay why
are you so get it
now give him my [__] Vape P so I do
have I no not now no so we have funny
stories toan about Patrick and how he's
a piece of [__] but we can do that as
this game progresses there's many of
time to how dare you insult Patrick how
dare no you don't understand dude the
guy could have won an Oscar I'm not
insulting him he was I wasn't lying I
wasn't lying the story is about me lying
I wasn't lying wood wheat sheep
regardless uh I I'm going to tell it for
years for years cuz hey get my name out
there just impressive yeah I pick mine
intelligence was my second one that
can't be done I forget where I put my
second
settlement I'm just going to say it's
the brick the wheat this one oh yeah
okay yeah well you she gets to pick
[__] you know people get to pick a lot
of things in life yeah cuz this is
capitalism yeah I agree with it yeah we
should let money decide everything and
then give that money to a small number
of
people
goam all
right let us fight now
packer darari d e p a r i just adult
kiddo cuz if they did yeah an adult
adult kiddo don't follow me doesn't
[__] she a good it doesn't [__]
matter dude I think it's just Zach
Silverman just regular old Zach silver
we're [__] playing good no no h on
the SE just no h on the
SE Silverman if you want to follow a
Jewish
man he's the right one to follow hey
nobody here should ever follow Patrick
darari please do not follow him Patrick
darari is a guy of character that should
be not be trusted go look at gareth's
Instagram and then realize that you
there's like a picture of my mom and
there's a couple pictures of Comedy you
know I didn't have an Instagram for like
two and a half years I don't Fu pictures
of him doing comedy no actually none of
me doing comedy not even pictures of him
doing comedy I've been doing this sniff
bit do you guys like it do you guys
you're not being mean you're being
accurate that's literally the truth
there's do the listeners like my sniff
yeah I should do something about that I
don't want to hold your hand yeah do it
no I know I need to very soon do you
have my
VAP I had a show it went successfully it
was all right minutes my family L let me
hit the Vape uh Hans told me at uh my
show that he [__] my
mother that's how BR that's how he broke
that news
to
um God
damn me I'm a buzz kill hello you're
live with Hans Kim radio what do you
have to
say that sounds
horrible hello buddy how you doing
you're live on Hans Kim podcast what do
you think about the things going on and
do you have anything interesting to
say hansin podcast I was trying to order
some take
out what would you
like uh do you have um sour
soup sounds
like um is it cuz I'm Asian ha
what what do you think about
um whose turn is it what do you do for
what do you do for work relax this is
why you lose what do I do for work dude
[__] what does it have to do with
anything
involving welcome to the yellow tiger
what would you like today Patrick you
shut your [__] mouth I like sweet and
sour soup I would
also
like
uh what where are you calling
from I'm calling
from California Southern
California
do that was rude hello welcome to the
hansin podcast what are you up to
tonight oh yeah hang up two hang up on
that who was that dude
hello Hi how are
you I'm okay just watching you guys
Heather's sounds
sexy hell yeah oh he's watching us
watching
I'm watching you guys with the chat boys
all the chat boys are watching you guys
chat boys chat boys in the house who's
your favorite sounds like thank you H is
my favorite
definely [__] kiss ass piece of [__]
[__] that guy Sim [__] his [__]
later dude you're very loud
G head you guys are like a family this
too aggressive who's your least favorite
you can't do it there you [__] you
like my sniff bits word is the camera do
you like my sniff
bits oh
yeah just say
yes to say oh yeah hey everybody
everybody shut up what's
that that's [__] funny that's comedy
baby all right baby all night okay don't
call me no no I don't like this anymore
you're talking you got two horny wait
wait a second this are both of your
parents still
[Laughter]
alive we get it you Mom you guys
seriously call yourself chat boys you
can't think of like a hans's homies or
something like [__] fat
boys all right got you guys got you guys
good oh Jesus Christ someone said to
look out the window oh oh no that scared
me [__] which
one
it's Doc it's doc out Amy is her name
wait oh wait what are you trying to say
ASMR you said
Amer Heather sniff bitsky thanks
[__] more like sniff
[__] hea sniff [__] peie I have a
question to chat wait are we playing
what's happening your turn Patrick
Patrick here's my question to chat is
literally yes a long time did yeah you
went twice dude Patrick wait did I I'm
I'm drunk I don't did I really oh Hans
Dynasty aggressive Hans that's good yeah
dude Korean calm down okay well I mean
I'm Korean I'm not
Chinese the Han Dynasty it's close
enough though it's like calling Germans
French people yeah yeah it's like dud no
one wants to get Hans do a minute of
everyone in Asia just copies China yeah
thick boy comedy China is I'm one of the
boys diick boy comedy yeah I'm one of
the boys the your whole family wanted to
know my name yeah remember that [__]
that was so ridiculous yeah that was so
ridiculous
ridiculous why is this so funny to me
cuz you're a good person I love you
Heather thank you shut up
K don't even all right who's going wait
what you roll I up your second
settlement roll I didn't roll yet hether
okay does anyone have extra pair of
headphones no no I'm wearing earbuds
shut up HS dude my podcasts or 10 10
wait what am I on wait
wood calm down
Heather this is how the game is played
oh [__] I could have done something on
myoll did I roll I feel like you guys
are lying to me what can you not do that
I definitely did not roll we haven't
this is the first role the game that's
how long it took for everyone to place
their settlements God oh cuz Patrick won
first okay oh question for chat yeah is
any of are any of you women I mean is
there one woman in the chat where my
[__] where [__] at
dude fellow litties I was very upset why
didn't you just tell me I wasn't upset I
was just
disappointed yo where the white women at
upset dude way the white women at
disappoint over my biracial ass I was
very I was like dude especially if
you're playing Katan you don't just
invite random people cuz then we have to
set up a completely different board for
five well Derek it would have been fine
if it wasn't Derek you know that you
honestly knew that yeah but it was Derek
that was the whole point it was
dere me
why I was not on Bo
with I never do it again I swear I know
I'm one of the boys but I want no he
looked at me dead in the eye and he was
like no me and Hans are cool now he did
my show and we're okay I did do his show
but I don't want to hang out with
it seven but that's exactly what he said
he was like he did my show we're okay
now I guess and then I get to the door
and Hans is about to beat the [__] out
of Derek like when I open the door he's
like wait who the [__] is this right now
I like the [__] I was like did not say
that you did say that said you're not
he's not welcome here you're not welcome
here he maybe a little worse it's like a
it's like a well the rights of the home
the
host is a very sacred uh Bond and you
just thrust upon me what did your old
the [__] comment Yo chat spam is Zach
is
Jew give me a card let me see oh
[__] I'm not doing [__] [__] you
[__] it's because of the resour thank
you that's what I needed that's what I
was looking for that's why I asked dude
Dale's gay he follows wait Dale's on
here D Dale was on here last time I love
you D on the no I didn't Dre that that
was you I love you baby hey can the chat
watch these [__] cheaters over here
yeah Z call them out or chat call out if
they cheat please for the love of [__]
is Zach is so cute says Corin that's why
I asked if there were any women I needed
to hear that I needed that win yeah have
you seen that compilation of Zach
Sullivan from Superman getting
complimented for his looks and how it
pisses him off and it puts him in a
super awkward position I am my turn and
it
justers your turn I believe I already
went oh no you R the seven yeah so it's
hans's turn I apologize I'm not a
germaphobe if anyone's wondering I just
like to filter a vape my
shirt genuinely questioning I once
rolled 77 sevens in a row you roll a
seven again yeah damn dude Patrick on
going [__] what do you think spent the
money on my mama's house and the rest on
peace Christopher come
on come on
Christopher I don't want to call anybody
out Christopher's probably a really rad
ladies in the chat any [__]
girlies I already asked no there aren't
any ladies on this chat are you [__]
kidding me Heather we're playing Katon
right now you know
what Katana is for women too dude it is
for now you're going to make me to 2022
dude wh women be settling in K women be
settling yes women be settling for all
of time men are trash look if there are
any women that play Katon please play
Katon with us for what for brick Oh I
don't have any brick what about sheep n
what about wood for Brick what do you
want brick brick brick I give you brick
what hey Bobby for Brick wait relax
brick yeah what do you want no I I
recently discovered that I don't I need
to shave my head my buzz my head you
wait yes relax
definitely
e hey so nobody trade with Hans cuz he's
a Shifty piece of [__] yeah but every
single time every single [__] game we
play everyone gangs up against Hans and
then somebody else is Win somebody else
Wins part of my strategy because I I
punish you guys for going after me by
losing yeah and that way you're always
suspicious that is fun I look like uh
Haley Joel OS that's true thanks
what's a consp that's a good question
what's a conspiracy theory you guys
think is real JFK was assassinated by
the American conservative movement
harlon's father actually where am I oh
[__] yeah I get a [__] meat
dude I got a six was the r Heather
embodies the uh pleasure you get when
your number is rolled does anybody
have a
brick yeah what do you want what
um I want ack for a brick I have a brick
I what do you want yeah sorry what do
you have I have offer me two things can
I have wood you want a wood
yeah or hay ha or wheat I'll do wheat
okay sick give me a second is the town
you don't have to vocalize every the on
your turn dude I [__] why do I always
[__]
up somebody said is like I'm going to
trade with everyone build a road right
there that's you don't have to say it
out loud pans is a communist you know
what I want to say I know this is a
podcast of us playing I don't want you
don't have to say you're playing someone
said Heather think swearing makes her
funny you is the r what's the number you
know what n true n I'm not even going to
[__] argue with you cuz anyone have a
wood for a brick I have a brick anyone
have a
wood for a brick sure you think you're
you think you're making fun of me but
it's just [__] true who's making fun
of who [__]
[__] cro I'm dyslexic I can't say their
name other things swearing oh you just
said it again what the [__] say it a
third time [__] see what happens stop
they're not here see what [__] happen
happens
you dick what do you guys think about
the uh nature of existence I love all
Jes wait what did you Ru do we even
exist or are we just thought wait what
did you roll what does that even mean a
nine no you don't have I mean don't you
think to think means you exist 10 were
you asking me or everyone the whole
group does anyone have brick
no we are what we are matter and I think
we all project what it is that we do on
everyone else and that affects
everything Z is Ador wait is that a girl
making fun of me dude women got to stick
together what the [__] are you doing
dude um I think for the most part
there's no meaning to life so you kind
of have to make your own six so you
don't have to yell dude yeah I mean that
life is just subjective and hopefully we
try to make it a good one before we die
I don't really why the [__] were you
yelling we all heard six say it one more
say fourth time say I think I'm funny CU
I swear side distraction to Friendship
I'm sorry I
apologize um I got to tame it I like you
but I think it's good to think about
philosophy and not ignore it because
otherwise what are we thinking about is
that a scar above your eyebrow a
chickenpox scar yes nice didn't have it
I recognize the chicken poox why are
your eyes so dead dead dead yeah I found
my mother
dead that only happened a year ago 3
years ago you should have been grown by
then you you should have let it affect
you this much did this really happen
yeah did you roll already I don't
believe I don't believe word he says I'm
still getting that whose turn is it is
it your turn G is it Hans turn
[__] six oh my God it's my turn I
apologize on see what [__] happens
dude uh does anybody want to trade for a
we're we're are we hitting on each other
at this
point what what do you think about the
uh wait who rolled what I'm so lost it's
too late you got a wheat okay but then
did I need a wood does anybody want to
trade for a wood I don't have anything
does anybody want to trade for wood have
please what do you think about the
Austin comedy trade me what would you
like um do you have a sheep I do I like
it a lot huh I think I'm trying to
answer your questions oops Yeah I mean
it's better than listening to these
people pray for the longest amount of
time possible H I'm more of a Pang dang
kind of guy you're a Pang danger I'm a
danger dude i' be danging that no I
think the scene
is for the most part like pretty bad
pretty
bad dude the spirit a spirit the course
is very high here the what the spirit
the cor the spirit of the cor the corpse
oh yeah I agree with that are you done I
done I my they didn't it's like the
energy and the Zeal of the scene is in
incomparable it is cool it is also like
roll I'm so I'm drunk too late oh I
rolled a six you rolled a six
again no you already got
your four four
obviously there's like clicks and drama
and stuff but for the most part it's
like pretty supportive to any drama
everybody shut up everybody shut up for
a second you shouldn't say that
[__] you like that [__] fart no stop
stop Garrett that's my thing top three
comedy cities that is myit
stch
Austin you like that New York La Austin
there's no third we're the third best
city now we made that Happ I would
definitely think seven seven yeah move
it
doggy wait who's winning no like before
third best was like what Chicago or
Boston or
Houston Gareth and I but mostly Gareth
is oh [__] you Hans no definitely go
I've literally never won a game of Kat
shut up is really good put on this eight
Wait no that's me on H's 11 that no you
that's where it was let me was I was on
kill Tony did you get go look up Patrick
toari on YouTube watch Patrick's
butthole is also all over the Internet
CU why the [__] not my butthole yeah he
won last time all over the
Internet [__] dude hey she are
valuable um does
anybody are you [__] [__] me
who
welcome to the game you can get out of
there you can get out of there I guess
but barely lots of sexual sexual tension
between Heather and no one in the
room I'm
[__] a I don't even have a comeback
for that that's is
funny isn't it kind of annoying that
Heather's my comeback is a maybe the
best why' you have to say that man
[__] you're right and I'm swearing
yeah all right
[__] now I'm now I'm now I'm insecure
about how much I'm
swearing oh my God what a
[__] 10 10 hell
yeah
brute I can't do
anything I think I'm going to lose this
one he stole my Rock part
oh no he's going to lose yeah don't be a
negative seven Jesus hell yeah put it on
Haun and [__] dude wait who put that
there put it on his six or his five or
rule of Katan if someone tells you where
to put it you put it there do that no no
no not me Hans Hans Hans dude give a
c I literally beat him last literally
everybody attacks Hans and we forget
about everybody else it's dumb no Hans
is after no read one book on Game
Theory he doesn't have the same Zeal for
beating me that you say he already won
last I dare you to say a sixth time he's
trying to win he's not just who is this
I want to Fu trying
inck I'll [__] fight you dude stop it
six
[Music]
[Laughter]
six listen to the men oh my
God honey is such a sweet but offensive
thing to call a woman I know listen to
the men honey sweetheart wait did
someone say that yeah [__] you dude that
was David
no
goodness nine
nine
no noise noise it's amazing how much of
the time your number doesn't get
the person who says I keep swearing
wants Zach to make out with
Hans me who the [__] is saying that you
swear to why are you listening to like
the Mothers Against Drunk Driving here's
the thing I I uh I'm insecure
roll the way you swear is no ELO oh my
God four well thanks I I really do
appreciate that four it gets me a bunch
of stuff God damn it it mean nothing got
see the Silver
Lining um does anybody have a brick yeah
I do what do you would like to trade um
yeah I'll do that here you go done
done man Gareth and Heather traded off a
lot this game I'll trade with you dude
what's up bro we'll trade eventually
don't worry we'll get there I'll get
there dude um I'm going to build a
road where uh Patrick do you want to
smoke a cigarette yeah eventually yeah
too yeah yeah it's so cold outside Vape
it feels good let's just do a lot of
stimulants and we should at each other
we should the more substances we do the
better tobacco and
marijuana I don't know if you guys know
this the amount of drugs you do is how
cool you are and how interesting you are
hey DAV would you agree with that yeah I
would agree with that and on top of that
I would also add that uh the more you
don't feel like yourself the better you
are [__] seven time dude say the
[__] seventh
time you like my sniff humor
still whose turn is
it it's Patrick's my
bad two yeah no way ited God damn it it
worked out where are you wait you have
two twos yeah wait
really D you picked a spot with two twos
that's so funnyes this Patrick wait does
anybody have a sheep no he doesn't he
has one two yeah he has two two right
next TR sheep for godamn it that's the
only way it' be worse if it was on a
desert all I want is a I'll do a rock no
I won't actually does anybody have a
sheep well no only way it can be worse
of anio Bill one road after 4 hours of
playing a weat or a rock what a piece of
you um where am I I'll do it for a rock
I'm sorry anonio if you ever see this
you're not a piece of
[__] everybody thinks you're a pedophile
but not a piece of
[__] I was just joking my friend Antonio
Rodriguez is not a
pedophile is that the guy that creeps
all the women out dude he every single
time he gets drunk he gets up in my face
last time he did it he got so close to
my face and I went hey you're too close
to me he went no I'm not I was like what
yes you are as if that's up to
you he hasn't had sex in 3 years long
I'm going to go but that's not his issue
he's just a crazy person in general but
I love him he's my friend I think
they're related Norm can I wear your
glasses obviously Stevie
100 what kind of
Zach reading the comments are you yeah
can you focus nothing's going on this is
so much more
my ears are so tight my ears are so
tight to my [__] head it's uh it's
penis so was accurate Zach's
turn passing the dyes is a very sacred
tradition very hard for oh will
six that was Jesus Christ can't people
like that can I have headphones um I'm
going to
buy I'm going to buy a uh I have El my
card oh you're so caring Karen Sharon is
Karen I
know Zach is a h this is why you were so
mad at me people like Zach man I
canar cat boys they like Zach what was
the number Zach oh dude you and Vermont
dude seven godam Zach stop being
fascinated by States no but I mean that
we did we used to do comedy in Vermont
that's kind of
oh you're so bad at this game uh I'm
going to play my night card oh come to
Comedy yeah Heather comedy oh I'm such
an idiot what's new hello caller welcome
to the Hans Kim podcast how you doing
tonight how's it going dude it's going
great uh how you been where are you
calling
from I'm calling from Oregon how your
[__] hole how big's your wiener
oh exact measurements not that big
that's a good answer
dude four and a half Z four and half
give me your [__] car why do you why
do why did you say it like that like oh
well it's not
great it's really not
great but it's not bad I have a 5.6 and
I'm ashamed of that it's like a
it could be wor it might as well be a
[__] did someone say
clitoris
perf [__] [__]
[__] whose turn is that so what do you
think
about Bill hick and glasses H I'm I'm
still not done this is not a great topic
to be talking about right
now tell us tell
us what do you want talk thing about
Heather is her oh well I
just about an hour ago I
took somebody asked a question I
answered how is your life going I don't
remember I six I really my life going
yeah how's your life going that ruin
that's tiny bro it is wait did you say
my name no I was asking if you were okay
you got to scroll up hans's name will be
highlighted he he posted the call the
number in the chat
no man I was asking
if are you okay boring to you no I'm
tripping what's wrong what's who
molested
you H don't nobody molested me I thank
God thank
God Andrew are you in a I did it before
you even said
it yeah I'm at home you're okay good but
I do I I do like Hans Kim I like Hans
Kim too what do you like most about
hansim shut up I'm G to end my turn it's
Hans Kim I like that you are
six did I get a we 11 did someone grab
me a weat what oh I'm sorry you like
that I'm a
what you're safe dude let me ask I'm
safe let me ask him a question well what
do they think about communism I feel
safe around Hans too you want
Rock what's your name Kidd I don't need
y what's your name
Andrew have you ever been like talking
to someone on the phone and you're
trying to be really serious you're
having a like a serious conversation
with them and then they hang up on you
yeah dud Patrick you [__] [__] I
know hey Gareth
dude hey Gareth can I have the
headphones yeah you can I I was
comfortable with them I know I really
like these actually am up can you please
give me
with the
downers no you know what happened David
is uh I was about to go to bed and then
Patrick was like you want to go play
Katana H I'm like sure and then they
started recording has a big ass [__]
then you started reading the chat
exclusively I have a really this isn't
very interesting yeah yeah no no no in
to
find small enough for me so they gave me
a helmet from like the' 70s and
everybody did this to me they were like
oh yeah cuz I had this giant giant thing
in the middle of my helmet it was like
the most ridiculous thing
ever wait is it my turn it is your
turn wait Hans is it her turn yeah right
can I have that back please it is eight
Darlings what the [__] wait what is
this you godam what the [__] that wasn't
me baby that was carth um does anybody
have a rock they want to trade me for W
I have no cards no I do not I'm sorry
come
on come on no I'm not training [__] off
dude um okay wait who has does anybody
have Rock car what's your social
security number they just don't want to
trade me I literally just have a wood
I'm too white for that does have that
you're not going to get
that everybody V
for what is this [__] dude I dropped
my card don't ask me a question like
that I'm much too smart for that Hans
where did you go to school oh can I play
it I went to school at
uh St St Edwards University and I would
love to tour with them let them know did
how long have you lived in Austin I uh I
lived here for 4 years then I moved back
to New Hampshire for 2 years then I
moved back here a year ago yeah so this
is my I'm the only person here from
Austin as always so six years total but
not consecutively two two baby jez patch
well going to St Edwards is pretty much
good enough call you an atin got it too
lucky dude terrible too I'm the I'm the
one who rolled it I've seen the city
change yeah I know dude I grew up here
anyone ever [__] literally have lived
here my whole life I thought you
followed someone here oh you went to
school here I went to school here that's
why I moved back cuz cuz things were
shutting down and I was like no wants to
trade with you I was going to move to uh
New Jersey and then like [__] shut down
I was like well at least in Texas I can
like be outside I heard you know I heard
comedies don't you think in an ideal
situation we should quarantine and not
let a disease
run only sentient species Universe yeah
but we all moved here to do comedy
during a pandemic lived here my reason
why we moved here to do comedy is
because the pandemic was prolonged and
worsened by people not
all you pieces sh it actually it was all
of us not staying inside not me I am my
I was
quarantining you were here early no I
was here in March I mean like if we're
not going to quarantine there's no point
in quarantining when no one is
quarantining unless you're going to die
from the disease sure I'm like a young
adult so it's not really a big deal go
off it's h but yeah I mean I think it's
disgusting to let people die just so you
can go shopping and I think we need a
re-evaluate our
perspective yeah I mean you know
whatever whatever we're doing I'm going
to do that's how I felt if we're going
to shut down I'll shut down but like it
didn't seem like we did H sounds like he
voted for [__] bid I was like if
we're not shutting down I'm not ruining
my
life um but I think that we should have
ruined our lives y know winning right
now and it makes me nervous you got four
points dude you a little nous in the soy
only Built one road I'm doing
terribly can I play a song I wrote don't
do just bu one road [__] can't oh no
so this is famous okay so if everybody's
watching this this is H his strategy
every [__] timeit what did you roll
it's called a
triangle he does this [__] every
[__] what did Hans roll just go I
literally in the group chat what did
Hans roll
Miss exactly they're all [__] always
so productive that's all [__] going
for you're so right who give [__] we
Zach
benett yeah Communists are lazy or
they're working too hard they can never
work
correct no ready I wrote a song it's
called Heather [__] [__] come [__] [__]
I like I had a conversation with someone
I'm not even like that does you are fat
dude does anybody ever Rock want to tr
that's not where I was
going does anybody have a rock they want
to trade me only a hey je that's the
cancer has spread to your heart
Jesus die any day the Beatles are going
to they're going to take down this video
whoever posted that Chan Gillis comment
it went away before I could see it
repost copy and paste it ter I don't
know what it said I know terrible
content wait
does anybody have a rock they want to
trade me for a wheat
um give me a rock I'll give you a weat
give me a rush I'll give you
really what was the roll what was the
number wait okay so now I'm going to
build a city is wonder
wall where do I want to build my city
you guys I think I can not vocalize
every part of your turn shut the [__] up
how they think swearing is
funny say it again say it again who was
it say it again say it an eighth time I
[__] dare you dude say it an eighth
[__]
time let me see I'm at one two three
points nice
nice all right it's Patrick's turn cuz I
look like Shane Gillis I get
it seven your face is just very
beautiful and funny but is yet seven
seven thanks man Hans I had you like
this com I remember talking to a friend
like about potic and he was talking
about how socialism doesn't work and he
was talking about like China and
Venezuela or whatever all the places
that didn't workum 2024 baby let's go
dude then but then I was like I don't
know man some
places does any asro world in like
Scandinavia it seems to be okay and he's
like that's like a really small country
you [__] Venezuela yeah it's like
well it's like okay now you're [__]
looking at context you know what I mean
like now you're going to analyze the
situation like these countries work for
the ninth time other reasons but these
countries don't work because commun yeah
I'm not going to like look at context
Hans always looks depressed that's just
his face
no I I mean what is the feeling anyways
it's just an emotion does anybody have a
rock a feeling is just an emotion no the
rockans dead inside like what's going on
over there hey does anybody have a rock
um I think I might have a chronic injury
that my energy no I'll give you a wheat
I'm good I'll give you two wheat I'll
give anyone two wheat for a
rock no say it a [__] 10th time dude
what was the role what was the number
dude all right you can roll swear to God
you won't it's only been get it to 15
times I'll [__] fight you I'll
[__] fight the DI say the [__]
11th
time hea what are you talking about
someone saying I Cur too much stop
reading the [__] text say a [__]
12th time dude eight say a [__] 12
time you [__] won't dude I swear to
[__] God you you won't say it a 12th
time dude so uh you think I should angle
the camera more downward no nine oh
baby just what the doctor or fing swear
to God you won't donate $500 right now
donate say a [__] 13 please donate
$500 to Gareth Dash Fisk that's g a r e
t h- f i k e I am in desperate need the
mafia is going to cut off my right pinky
toe if I don't get it like the next two
grand in four days I have three points
I'm not kidding this isn't a joke I need
the money please guys wait I just
thought of a I've been thinking about
this bit for a minute I just want to
present this bit to you guys
ready I was literally waiting for a
moment of silence to do
it what's all sniff the mic at the same
time yeah let's do it in unison let's do
it ready put your skin on it two one
all right that was just for just for the
viewers how many viewers in the chat how
many viewers in the chat let us know
little sniff bit how many viewers in the
H you mind if I grab another beer can
you grab me one wait no I I've got a
full one just kidding are they hard
sers
beers what did you roll an 11 no no no
you guys I got drunk who Dr the my sh I
know Patrick did you drink my shot yeah
didn't know you were drinking it I'm
sorry I was gone I'm
sorry
um sniff each other's purple mics what
does that even
mean purple
mics dicks aren't purple they're
pink or
brown you guys are going crazy over
there in the corner I am my
turn Heather i p this wait wait what did
Gareth roll r a nine you did yes okay I
don't have a nine can you give me a
brick 12 jokes on you none of us can
smell you have every one dot spot on the
map me
yeah you got a shut up no I got on that
side I got great numbers why did you
pick up a whatever a brick cuz he rolled
a nine I'm literally not that picking up
your cards from the last turn that's a
real no no my bad bro
[__] Patrick you piece of [__] is
anybody been watching is he cheating no
I I didn't know you were old N I wasn't
pay ATT Chad you've been watching did I
cheat I didn't pick up a brick chea H
doesn't do Coke stop asking about yay
Gareth pay attention to the game and
play better both [__] told me you
cheated earlier I cheated I don't
[__] do that [__] okay it's not cool
not oh my God another
two um wait what do I I [__] okay I'm
no I'm not going to oh look I have two
twos two ones now too I have two
12s blue is that you Heather yeah you
Heather is
blue oh no I dropped
it I swear all the time not just you got
four points you didn't say it a 15th
time who gives a [__] about Nancy Reagan
telling you swear too much like that's
literally the stupidest criticism ever I
love her I feel like she's a girl and we
comment I'm happy
[Music]
for [__] tell not to swear girl who's
making fun of me seven who's Brown
me get heather Hans dude I'm not even
winning winning winning dude no dude
don't let them change your mind what the
[__] you're we little [__] dude that
five that five cuz no come on dude not
that five [__] do what you because
that's valuable for right now we're all
in the same boat so it really doesn't
matter you [__] I got youit Ste
from you I don't have any cards I wasn't
going to steal from you Hans but I to
what the [__] man I'll just take them
off it's happened both times
now okay damn you blocked my brick and
then you took a
break [__] bre see I don't mind telling
everyone cuz it's not my card
anymore I have no relation to
it now you're using it you're a lesbian
dude going for longest road Wasing so
many [__] road that hurts my feelings
dude save your road and build a
settlement right here is that what that
means don't need more I I'm just paying
attention to does that mean he G $2 yeah
oh my God I love that guy soccer is gay
I love you dude [__] hate that outfit
Austin like am [__] dude this is why
do we have more
Sports hous in that area where that
[__] CU that's how taxes work so
[__] stupid no it's because all the
[__] politics here in a we had a
choice to have one or not and we chose
to make our city more interesting and
diverse by having a soccer team that
nobody really I don't have any fun
playing good T so much Jesus Christ in
Christ um this is not fun when you lose
at all no pay attention pay attention
there are a lot of people that really
care about Austin FC but I [__] could
give a [__] less it just causes traffic
all the people that it causes traffic
all the [__] people they come into
the robo room I [__] hate dude give
me a card
gy wait where did you your take
sucks [__] go I me if it's causing
traffic it means I thought you were a
lesbian why do you want to see Zach's
wood it's driving the economy yeah
what's happening here I got a 10 10 yeah
oh give me that wood St they're making
fun of you that's
funny H nailed
it what' you roll a 10 hey donate some
money if you want to see Patrick take
off his
shirt donate money if you want to see me
take my shirt off going to keep that I
really don't want to take my shirt off
it's not going to be fun for anybody
here but donate mine oh what you guys
want me to take my shirt off shut up Z
the only one who works out oh I get two
Bri I work out it just doesn't work out
dick
muscle why is it n r only but once it's
a shame dude [__] figure out your
sexuality I'm not going to help you on
this chat anyone watch no let's help him
that'll be fun her her yeah calm down
whatever you want be you be anyone want
brick could be they yeah you have wheat
yeah me don't [__] do it I'll give
you a wheat for a
rock one two
three
um anyone have I swear to God if anyone
calls me Lena Dunham I will kill myself
she doesn't look like Lena Dunham what
am I eating out my little sister looks
more like L Heather all right see that
was good that [__] Divine [__]
[__] you dud you said you said generic
white guys and I said yeah like Adam
Divine yeah which you get all the time
we've talked about that you know what
[__] you surf hearts a lot that's [__]
up that was good this the other [__]
is bad what was good I rolled an a I
called him
lham oh wait yeah Gareth I'm pissed does
anybody have a head like done if she got
really what did you roll eight I rolled
an eight does anyone have a brick for a
hay I will give you a brick give me a
hay please I'll give you ay for a oh
[__] yeah
dude hey uh can you hand the
ukul [__] if we get $50 in donations
I'll show my uh armpit calm down trying
to get hans's money
here and then I will build a
settlement P hey Zach can you put my
settlement on that
Port thank you and now it's Zach or
Patrick's turn but he's having he just
left to get a cigarette these nicotine
fiends wise
men say oh I have to Ru now sorry
fools
[Music]
russan but I
can't help what' you get falling in
love with you sounds like sh I got
[Music]
eight that be
a cuz I
can falling in
love with
[Music]
like a river
flows to the can I do a
solo calm down can I see the dice wait
did he Roll It
Roll okay
cool
but I'm
gay I like to suck dicks a
lot cuz I
I love
[__] right in
my
night
I you're so
annoying can I see the dice what the
[__] yeah no it's your turn wait you R
an eight give me give
no play eight can I please give me give
me I rolled another eight I didn't get
my full fix of it cuz you ruin it in the
middle
sorry wait what did you roll
eight give me that
[__] did everybody get their
[__] I I'm so insecure about how much I
curse now you [__] ruin me you
bisexual lesbian
[__]
I come on man
you're figuring
out did not appreciate what not getting
the
ukulele What's Happening Here do you
guys hate me wait I'm
anxious wait what's happening all right
it's Garrett's
turn give
me
wait
wait wait
oh wait is that some
Zelda [__] I forgot how to play
it [__] I forgot how to play
[Music]
it [__] this
sucks I forgot how to play it I'm so
sorry
come on stop you're not good at this
right
[Music]
now no you were right the first
time I'm going to go see what they're up
[Music]
to
I figured it out wait wait
[Music]
wait I [__] forgot I'm so
sorry give up the guitar and go back to
swearing
[__]
[Laughter]
you oh how was that couple seconds with
just these two my gosh really
autistic five bucks hey hey now follow
his lead
guys is that
audible
no whose turn is it oh it's gareth's
turn gareth's
turn
what did you roll uh eight
nine you roll eight what' you roll
[Music]
Patrick you you were here for it I I
rolled the I forget [__] you man tell me
what you roll no I forget I genuinely
forget what do you roll dude no I
genuinely
forget that's mean guys come on you were
here for it though no it's not I have
cards
oh I rolled an eight wait what did who
did I rolled an eight too who did what I
remember now I rolled an eight I ran in
piece of
[__] when all the funny people leave the
podcast that's no the person who said
get better
friends this is the best he can do do
you even know
Hans do you honestly think he could do
better than us you know
nothing can I say your your value card
I'm just a re big old
[Laughter]
idiot someone said this house definitely
stank my mom made split pea soup today
and I can't stop farting it's all I had
with the resing hairline today all I had
was where does your mom
live oh that's
me my mom's
address no thanks all right I was going
to say all I had today was Mexican food
a cold brew and
nicotine I'm not doing good do anybody
have wheat like to trade [__] no I
only have sheep have a what you have
sheep I have wheat what would you like
for that sheep would you like a brick
for that sheep one of those Heather I
have would you like a brick for one of
those sheep N I have wheat would you
like a brick for that sure okay how you
doing say a [__] 18th time dude or
are you at
17 I feel like we're going to kiss are
we going to kiss at this point you keep
talking about how I'm only funny when I
swear are we going to [__] kiss
[Music]
dude oh you son of a [__] Heather [__]
you what you house building
[__] damn
it what are you going to do I didn't
vote
[Music]
smells smells like feet no thank you
move out of Vermont why did you you live
in the woods so I use my shirt as a
filter because I don't like the the
sweetness of a vape there you go Mario I
just like nicotine I'm not a germaphobe
or anything I just like filtering it
[Music]
double [__] you so much
Heather
how do you have no wheat wait what and
how do you have some Gillis CAD whose
turn is that it's
mine yeah you're just ripping off Shane
no it's not the issue anymore I talked
to him he was really cool I was like oh
he was so cool he's not that cool I
would no he was so cool him so much no I
met him three times and I loved him a
lot I talked to him outside of Vulcan I
was so wasted
I I introduced I introduced her to
him I watched him tape his special his
special is good but the [__]
videography on it sucks I [__] hate
you so much there were so many
transitions it was it it hurt my brain
it was a new editor leave him alone he's
a good
guy that's what I have to say to
[Music]
that went back trading this I had traded
two of my sheep I for before I realize
that Heather is a piece of
[__]
[__] I'm not give me that uke [__]
it doesn't matter either way I can't do
anything here's a go f is mad at me at
this point cuz I'm drunk it's your turn
I [__] hate everything that took
forever five oh [__] give me that
double
brick move this is this yours
yeah godamn it relax you pour me another
shot I found a doar what a sweeth hat oh
yeah P another shot another sh Show me
your butthole Let's do let's someone
wants you to
flex oh no no yeah Flex all no no no no
take off your shirt no no what what are
you go watch kill Tony with uh David
Lucas God oh go watch Tony he takes his
shirt off what episode number is that uh
let me look right now did you guys see
my he takes his shirt off on kill Tony
go watch that [__] I did the Blues it's
actually a funny set he has too 514 514
episode 514 of kill Tony I did 512 I
think do you guys like me 2.1 million
I'm drun pleas validate he's a funny
[__] guy stop GTH dude you had to
build a
house people love Z dude I just want
people to like me dude
we all love nobody likes me I don't get
it what did I do why don't you guys like
me what is
it no one
responds oh he asked again you [__]
asked again God his questions are so sad
trying [__]
sayri you're look at your stupid
head what about brick anyone want brick
for what I'm so in love with that
comment it's so funny to
me uh you what you brick Bing Bong for
what rock um no what
about no I'm good I I've gotten up
[__] nothing wait what did you roll
you rolled five I already got my [__]
watch right you
remember this is hard to watch this
funny yeah don't watch you cannot watch
wait just be yourself guys oh we're This
Is
Us people let talk to their lives n we
don't care about have like a great Katan
SES like we always do and then they'll
enjoy it or
not look at the comments we should
interact all right I'm going to play my
night we should just and I'm going to
move it to the six great cuz I want to
[__] you guys over give me your card
Hans oh you turning off the oh my
goodness
give that makes me
sad are we not reading comments anymore
no we're not reading your comments
anymore just kidding it's still up there
keep commenting no it's not everybody
[__] flood the chat flood the chat so
much that we can't even read it please
wood I don't give a [__] anymore you
traded in one sheet I traded in four
sheet take it back and I'll give you
never mind I don't have a wood my bad
what was a roll I'm going to put it
right here
cuz just cuz just cuz that's just my
cuz
nine we not every [__] time with the
GTH G like your neighbors why did I feel
like someone was missing everyone's here
right yeah the chat is gone we're
waiting no I'm saying I thought someone
here was gone well we should have six
people we're waiting for we're waiting
for D does anyone have a can stand that
guy but it's not my fault cuz he said
the NW on stage no one can stand him
he's the one who booked me for the Plus
siiz show does anyone does anyone have a
to get me to get closer to him does
anyone have a rock
no feel bad I'll give you two week wheat
okay guys I got okay twoo weat for a
rock just talk talk [__] about people we
know sorry I'm just yeah who's your
least favorite people in the scene guys
that's such a negative comment dude who
are your top five least favorite comedy
Bookers in Austin
Texas dang it Brian redbear huh
Dam your top five least favorite
clubs oh my
God we Mike's coming from the ceiling so
that we can see the board
better
[__] Teddy I forgot I to I'm over there
also can I have some G can some Teddy
Gams of course I'm so sorry I don't want
to hog you take the box dude thank you
no take the just be the
[__]
is oh wait what did you roll still
L nine nine nine I roll a nine roll a
nine okay I rolled a nine what the [__]
yeah
dude makes gar a rich there so much m
noises going on in these headphones
sorry where's the Box
stop does anyone have a brick they want
to trade for a wood yes wait uh yeah
that was
quick
settleman good job go ahead calm
down n nine again what the [__] it's
awesome it's bad for us Spirit of the
night it's really good for me dude about
to [__] y'all
up
okay I hate you so much Heather I just
want that to be
know you on statement what happened well
I wanted over here oh oh I have three I
forgot about that cigarette like a dirty
filthy tarong person you built two roads
and now they're wasted exactly well they
couldn't I can
still now H I feel disconnected from the
audience I don't like it yeah you should
bring the chat back up we won't pay
attention to it as much it does kind of
it does kind of the worst reason to
bring it back up Patrick you have been
nothing but paying attention to that
chat you promoted yourself you need I
didn't even know that the chat was gone
your penis isn't as big as your head you
need to calm down it's pretty big though
I just want to you pull it up on your
phone big ass head that's
true yeah but then I'm the only one
reading it and it's it's weird I'll give
you compliments all the time dude here
can you me liveing from YouTube or the
VAP please
yeah yeah I'm sorry I'm I'm manipulating
my
thoughts trying to project something oh
I [__] look crazy dude I thought that
would look cute it's
not if I have a road Patrick's a small
dick fat [__] shut the shut the chat
off that's awesome I really love say
that no nobody actually said that oh
damn it um Hans can I if I move if I
build a road right here is this a
connected road to these roads or is that
one two build a road right now does that
make four or does that make five four I
built a road
okay I you roll I on my hair I rolled
another nine D oh my
goodness wait you rolled a nine again
yes I did I hate
you just want you to know
that
okay yeah we're all
autistic I'm not thanks for noticing I'm
[__] not
dude
we could just ask like kill Tony
questions like how's your dating life
you got any hobbies it's like I do
comedy every night without you was
something crazy that we wouldn't have
asked you I found my mother dead shut up
all the bits
over
yeah
so was it
like yep she died horribly or was it
just like oh yeah good
question definitely
horribly do you think she was like oh I
hope my son doesn't find me like this
that was her last thought yeah she said
leave the room I don't want you to see
this Patrick did your mom die dude I
think so I think maybe this real did you
ever like see evidence of it I don't
know the blood on my baseball bat was
pretty
clear at least you're
strong H would be strong to kill your
own mother like Carl Grimes have
emotional [__] Grimes her oh let's
not talk about that have you really that
is the first time I did comedy literally
oh you're one of those guys one of those
do you get it chat do you get it now
yeah people the people who are like
first doing their first time on
kill there was one guy who was he did it
his first time his first time on stage
was on kill Tony and I went up to him
after and I went hey are you going to
start doing open mics now and he went no
I'm just going to keep doing kill Tony
and I was like what yeah people uh tell
you right now don't kid Pony it's
usually not a good call wait what did
did you roll already to get good at a
time where's the longest road I
like uh that will end my
turn
cool five
seven move the robber and I punish evil
the the evil doer who [__] me do you
have development cards three
four I don't have to answer that Dam it
dud I have the right to remain silent
one two three 4
5 to win right now you're such an idiot
stop being an idiot G I'm stealing from
you GTH you have seven points you're
winning you're so paranoid H is going to
[__] win dude thanks for your faith
in me but it's kind of creepy right now
no you're a piece of [__] and I hate you
and you have the triangle pattern going
and I don't like it this is so weird
that people are watching us I can't get
over it yeah you never like like do
things in front of people turn off the
chat again so she stops thinking about
this seriously should I turn off the
chat again that's true that's in the no
chat for you listen Hans I need
attention Heather we all love you stop
mugging for the camera what does that
even mean dude it means stop performing
for them and perform for us no no that's
fair you know what hey that's fair and
i' be swearing Hans move into a house
because of Gabby
ptio Gabby that's [__] funny yeah
that was a good one that's why I said it
it's exactly why I said it no it's
because of the children
who is Gabby ptio the lady that got
murdered oh cuz it's like van lifers are
being lynched right now like the Jews is
that what's happening yeah we're
persecuted dude Jews are doing fine can
I
want for what wood no wait give me one
second no do it don't do it don't do it
don't do it no I can't do that you want
a brick youone have wood I can't do that
yeah I'll trade a wood for a brick okay
oh God damn it s godam damn it anyone
you want to do it again you're winning
but no anyone want brick anyone want
sheep you want to want sheep no wait
actually wait maybe you want wheat or
sheep or brick um can I do a wheat and
sheep for a
brick uh yeah you want to I look like
haly has at least two victory points
right now it's it's that's the third
comment stop the third person saying I
look like him can't do that Sor I look
like him [__] what can you do did I say
brick I get that every day every day say
brick every day I get that every day I
call you I go hey you look like haly J
my dad tells me I'm happy that Haley
jman's my
son
Bano I could have got two rocks I
guess um my only wait Heather you got an
only fans no dude she's not good-looking
enough
have an sexualize everyone come
on even though I why wouldn't you ask
anyone else here huh do they have an
only fans do they have do they have do
they have they don't want to see us
naked they want to see you
naked just fine what do you guys think
about Heather's I
roll did you
R tell
us I wait give me one second am I on a
port H that's not I am wait my
bad okay I'm going to switch three brick
wait wait what did they say the guy in
tan looks like he could be Rosio
Donald's female sub Heather swears for
free say a [__] 20th time you
[__] hey Marty I want to let you know
[__] your mother got him wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait he got I can
trade three for this three for that no
this is why' you okay I'm going to trade
three I'm going to trade six brick for a
wheat and a sheep and then I'm going to
build a [__] settlement dude you
don't have to vocalize every
turn you can't build the settlement
where you going to build a settlement
out right there oh [__] that's the only
place I can go and that brings me up to
two 3 four what do you think about Lou
CK's new special that was so good we
were watching the other day so good yeah
second time watched it was are you done
front to back man front to back I liked
I like sincerely a lot more actually but
this was good was good seven seven seven
that's not what about you Hans what do
you think thought it was good I thought
some of his views were a little problem
time I [__] dare you some of he's
like Millennials are right but they're a
little [__] about some of
the things that was kind of yeah he's
like quarantining why would we do that
but I mean I thought he was good at
doing that at being well yeah the whole
thing is like we were all told that if
we go outside millions of people will
die and then we did and millions of
people
died not to spoil the jokes 12 oh my
goodness wow
[__] off with your 12 helps to invest in
the twelves wait where' The Vape
go give me give me give me I'm going to
build a road hold on I was going to hit
this say it a [__] 2 first time I
[__] I liked um I liked it I don't
know I don't want to like spoil the
jokes but like can you not be so sloppy
with the dice
sack um what do you guys think of my
looks that's that's really what we want
to
know what it's already on my [__] dude
say the [__] 20 second time I dare
you get to 25 and I'll [__] fight you
dude I know I said that about 15 but
would anyone like to trade um for a
rock I'll give you a brick for a rock no
I need a rock oh never mind I don't have
any cards Z I have no
cards what about you no how about uh I
give you
uh uh
a wood and a brick for one
sheep woodn't a brick for one sheep no
what are you going to do about it you're
not going to do
[__] do you're not going to do anything
you [__] idiot stop being so
mean I [__] hate this chat I'm going
to um build a road C yeah I got a rock
for a
[__] one two three four I'm going to end
my turn dalen are you are you here still
is DAL still
here no
way wait listen to this
ASMR
is that gross probably
was here you go okay thank
you heather is special in a special kind
of 12 I rolled a [__] 12 idiots two
sheep for Hans thanks God damn it Hans
how different has your life become since
you become a regular and kill
Tony um it's been very different it's
like I get treated very well and I have
a lot of favors and a lot of nice things
happen to me now and it's like how
comedy I thought it would be when I
first started oh that feels nice does it
did you notice like literally overnight
people like kiss kissing your ass like
um I mean it was gradual I mean I feel
like I've been uh yeah I mean it's like
it seems like it was
like um 11 like a continuation of a
process
yeah but yeah I mean comedy is like an
interesting art form yeah where you
don't get anything for a while and then
you get too much yeah I'm going to play
night and
um move
it right here no no Hans Hans you're
winning gett Hans has two Victory Point
1 two three four five Hans has two viory
he has the longest yeah you're winning
damn Gare I'm certain you're
winning what an idiot all
right eight
eight oh I get a [__] sheep
dude I get a sheep are you still mad at
my
Whispering I'll trade you a wood
for a sheep or a
stone everybody have a show a stone or a
weat or stone or a sheet for a
trade I do I do I do intensely read
chats you want wood you have wood paying
attention to it
thanks would you like to do that again
no guys like this would you like to do
that for a St or a week no it does seem
I've heard that from a lot of people
I've heard like show businesses like
that
where like it's just like eating dick
for years and then all of a sudden you
do it like oh but it's like very
ancillary because like in uh can you me
because like in standup comedy it's like
very face to face so it's not as crazy
as like acting like it's more like a lot
of the fans are online too so I only see
them when I go to the
events right I noticed that last time I
went to kill Tony everyone is asking you
for pictures it's so weird just cuz I
know you as Hans and everyone's like
Hans somebody asked me for a picture of
Kony because they saw my set oh now I
don't feel that good why it always dead
well I'm just saying it feels really
cool it's like wow cool I was like
really like I was like genuinely do all
you have to do is stand and it's like
your general presence I approve of and
enjoy and he was like well you're not
like something now but like eventually
and I was like oh okay well that's
[__] sick well you didn't nice
compliment you just take the picture and
I'll be like you're like ethereum to
me he's like you're jack [__] now but if
you keep doing it for 10 years you'll
get
good anyone want sheep or brick I do
I'll give you a sheep for I'll give you
a sheep for a week I mean I'll give a
for a wheat three sheet for a wheat shut
the [__] up
dude he's right there trading with me
can I have a the P please
no yeah dude I'm giving roll
hun um a
six's anyone have wood no I'll give you
a wood for a sheep
okay about to win right
now I'm not even paying attention to the
G what is all this over here is are all
the Cs that I already paid
with you
[__] you got me you got me dude okay I
think I'm
done was going to put a nice line in the
eight you get a sheep eight Jesus yeah
sheep your Jew hands grubbing up the
resources does anybody have any Rock
they want to give
me no are you
sure are you positive I've got two sheep
I'll give you two sheeps for two
Rock two
sheepies two
Rockies driving home with you is going
to be really annoying tonight you have a
rock Heather too busy worrying about her
next meal hey guys you want a sheep no I
need a
rock like I'm good thank you okay
Patrick yeah do you look as ugly as
Gareth
gareth's a very [__] off with these
nines just like very solidly average
looking man we already talked about how
generic looking no you're you're F you
got a great chin a little chin dude it's
an extension of his neck oh I got this
turkey neck right yeah lose some weight
what are we working out again dude
what's Happ let's do it I'm down oh
really do 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 like a
sick ass gy nice a sick ass gym a gym
for your ass I mean you can work out
your ass
prologist my do my job as a
proctologist it's a perk yeah he sticks
things in my ass and I
Lynch yeah you got to be one more I'm
losing
connecting damn we're all going for
longest rad I already have
[Music]
it I'm doing uh Patrick could do it I
could do it does anybody Z could do
it wait what the [__]
dud yeah but if I connect mine I need
three more rides no I'll give you a
wheat for a brick no
does anybody have a rock I'll give you a
rock I'll give you a wheat for a rock no
a wheat for a rock or a brick no no a
wheat for a rock you need
Sheep No don't do it Heather how many
points are you at stop telling people
what to do this is America five six
that's what America no I'm
good everyone
2ri 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
eight have six cards I don't believe you
1 2
[Music]
3 oh I get three
hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey going to build a city shut
up one two three four five Gareth has
eight points already 1 2 3 4 5 six again
[__] me seven wait really yes
really nobody roll a seven I'll be
pissed it my
turn S your thing season
30 that's pretty
good 11 God damn it 11
oh oh I get a rock baby nine four be
really great right
now this is
good this is good the silence right now
that's good Katon dude it's intense so
what do you think about hate you so much
dude um Zach Silverman you think that
he's maybe too awkward on stage you know
I used to say when me when me and my
comic friends and Zach would hang out
Zach being one of my comic friends I
would say you know one day we're all
going to be so good at comedy and Zach's
going to be a great manager for
[Laughter]
us
anyone it is true though Zach would
actually be great
if we were to go on a tour if we were to
go on a tour and
everything we be like Z set it all
up what about you are winning you have
technically more point you have eight
points I have seven you have a brick you
have no I want a brick do you have a
rock wait what are these
cards Dude I have so many cards she if I
roll a seven I'm going to be F I don't
what about rock for a brick I don't have
a brick I thought I did I don't have a
brick I have a wheat I'll give you a
wheat for a rock I have it to trade you
want a wheat for a rock uh
yes as God damn it I [__]
ha are you done yes okay don't roll
seven 10 10 wait do I have a 10 oh I do
I get a wood
[Music]
okay um this game is all about picking
up your resources when your number gets
rolled okay I'm
trading rock that is actually legit a
good game design that you get to play
every turn yeah that is and then I'm
going to build a city fun and you get a
little reward yeah yeah just like yeah
it's I'm going to build my
city I think I'm going to build my city
I think also fun to strategize longterm
and build an Empire give me one you
don't have to say this part out loud oh
my god
um wait do long-term thinking and like
the strategy and the King we that we
it's like such a good part of time to
think about the same
strategy I'm build what's that this
tripod that's a killer strategy dude hey
who inspired you guys to be a comedian
who was the first comedy special you
saw it's so cliche but Sarah Silverman I
can beat all of you well any answer is
cliche because we all saw [__] M
ComEd yeah what if you're like if Sarah
Silverman
but someone who's not cliche like
[__] Jeff Dam yeah Larry the Cable gu
good that's Ridge herburger yeah true
honestly have a that's what he said I
believe
it like he he got a catchphrase like
nobody has a rock get her done
or nobody has a rock for a sheep uh no
okay who was y's first person yall saw
alive in general live Todd Barry Lor
good watch
CR so good Alicia wood nobody has a rock
for a sheep who is yours she's like a
local Seattle
comic I had never seen comedy live and I
went to kill Tony that was my first
comedy actual
so no Brian Redban went up first so
Brian redb was literally the first ever
show standup com comedian I saw show no
kill Tony they did a comedy show they
did a comedy show before it oh and then
Tony kinch Cliff went up it was it was
uh
it it was back before the pandemic so
they had the band still uh so they had
uh so red band went up first and then
uh um the drummer there I forget his
name Joel yeah Joel Jimenez and then uh
jety Johnson there and then Tony went up
nice and it Jeremiah wasn't there but it
was a great show and then they and then
they did Kill Tony after what was it 11
was that fun oh it was great so that was
uh so you were a fan of kill Tony before
before you started doing comedy yeah I
was a huge fan and then I started doing
comedy and now I don't watch at all why
I just I just don't I've seen it live so
much I see it live so often that I'm
like it doesn't feel the same yeah
there's no point in really fun live it's
way better it's way better live I only
watch it when like someone I know is on
it and I want to see their set and then
I'll watch their set and I'm like I
don't want to sit through there care
Seattle lady that you saw what was her
Alicia wood Alicia wood cool man I was
in chat nooga and she was like playing
at the local Club so I went to see her
oh want to be a comedian that's awesome
anybody have a brick Zach what was your
favorite wait uh the first comedian I
was like I don't the first comedian I
was like into I've never seen him live
but the first comedian I was like into
was Demitri Martin really yeah Demetri
Martin did you watch
seen first person you saw though that
was the question I don't remember cuz I
I think cuz I just went to like a local
Showcase in New Hampshire I don't
remember
turn [__] sh cun 10
TW what's another good swear word what's
a good swear word you guys Blockhead
does anyone have a weat uh hold on you
Chang I can say [__] that's the only
slur I can say does anyone have any weat
I can say [__] no no I can say [__]
I'm H I eat [__] the first comic that I
saw was car one ever I was damn you saw
saw Carlin live died years old give me
the Vape wow that's [__] awesome dude
Fu crazy what year uh I me I was like
eight or nine I don't know do the math
on that I'm 27 right now [__] you
Heather 19 years
ago scis 2002 2001 sound like that man
but I was in uh galon and I saw him at
some theater wait what was r i I don't
remember most of his is good guys but he
was in all black and he came out into a
blackout stage and I was sitting pretty
close to the front and he just
goes [__] fart and like the whole
[__] crowd erupted it was the coolest
thing ever it was that stage of to him
yeah absolutely St he he's [__] great
yeah Heather you he's so great and he's
so
dead he's so rotted in the ground it's
crazy I heard he had money problems so
he had to work till forever yeah he had
a uh presidency in Vegas when he died
that's what he was doing when he died
yeah which is like he got arrested with
Lenny Bruce for uh yeah defending Free
Speech oh [__] yeah that's why they're
the Pioneers that's why they're the
that's why they're on the mount Rush is
funny when people are like you can't say
anything now it's like people used to
get literally arrested for doing comedy
I H's got M at me for my sniff
bit you can sniff just don't do it so
close to the the
mic wait do I have a 12
no why would you notice that Stevie 100
that's crazy four five six s
eight what did you go through his whole
following what the
[__] he follows DK Temple what are you
talking
about a reference that nobody
gets hey Derek saw Pig on anyone have
sheep or anyone have
brick no I have cards do you want sheep
for what I don't have brick for Brick no
I don't have any brick what about wood
for Brick for Brick I don't have Bri
trade with him he's shiy I'm I literally
don't have any brick what about rock for
Brick I literally don't have brick I
don't have brick shut the [__] up [__]
you hun I'm not giving you
[__] oh like you know I see where you're
coming from I agree with that
that Chrissy d a lot of comics nowadays
are such better podcasters than standups
cuz standup is a shitty thing to watch
on a like a just a special is you want
this not great
Patrick bang you have wood do any good
stand up Gareth do anything watching
Gare [__] I don't want sheep at least I
have I have dude [__] life I've never
seen him give me the Y you're being so
[__] creative right now give me the
goddamn let me hit it for a while I move
it over butt hurt [__] [__] you Hans
over this can someone just [__] win
already H is going to [__] win like I
have been saying this whole goddamn time
who has wood nobody I don't have wood or
brick I have you li last
time OU
God I hate you so much
H Ro
um okay I win oh nice do you really God
damn it dude for any new viewers in the
chat go follow Packer deari on Instagram
and go watch living with a sped on
YouTube you can search living with a
sped Roid Rage an episode will pop up
and then you can find the page from
there subscribe like comment you know
all those things it's a great show four
season series it's really good no
budget you can also catch Patrick on
grinder it's the app where men have sex
70 feet away yeah Gareth knows that when
he checked grinder in the
bathroom I hate you so much
Hans 1 2 3 4
five six seven points 1 2 3 4 5 6 six
points 1 2 3 4 five oh that's me 1 2 3
four who whose turn is it Five Points 1
2 3 four 5 six Hans won yeah I got my
ass
kicked who what the [__] dude I had
Gareth was right dude you guys should
have been more careful of
me a that makes me so sad you want to
play again what time is it let's play
another one yeah no 213 I'm so
tired well I mean it it's not like it's
the latest I've ever PlayOn Hans you
want to play a [__] Twan Katan
game well Gareth can give Zach a ride
and then we can play just three player
yes's not game let's do it dude oh
Heather's game bro Heather's in it you
can just drag her along she'll do
whatever I hate you so much
that was a good game that was a good
game that sucks I didn't get my longest
road I'm never going to win I'm never
going to [__] win dude oh
[__] yeah [__] one out like oh got a
different major surprise I thought we
were way behind that's ridiculous you
ever played coup that's a good one clu
Clan yeah I love that [__] my name my
name I want yall to know this it's not
g it's G it clan it's spelled g a r have
you guys been able to hear Gareth this
whole
time unfortunately no one wants to hear
you Patrick can you have a [__]
microphone you piece of [__] all right
that one Asian kid my bad
bro hey he's Asian hey back off he's
Asian again it's you weird a r e Gare
please please have a normal conversation
don't be doing bits for the [__] chat
that ages very poorly I want doing bits
for the chat I was spelling my name why
we all know your name here I don't yeah
you're doing bits for the chat you dumb
[__] you want to play another
game you ready for a 6 hour podcast all
right we've been bucket
comedians are you really down for
another game hether I oh my God I
guess it's just going to be you me and
on really want to bring me home no I
don't want to take you home okay where
do you live outside [__] that
okay just play another game guess I'm in
for another [__]
game
do you always work I have work at
8:00 technically or
whatever don't show up dude 25 show up
I'm show up no I'm I don't want to Hans
do you have any
liquor I can't read shair man you don't
have any liquor I don't think so Katon
Kat look good you guys uh one of who's
playing I'll play oh my God come on
Heather you want to play no don't the
viewers want it Heather I'm game to call
it if you are we can crash this whole
thing right now yeah I can't play oh
thank God I mean I'm game I guess but at
the same time
you want to play
I'm let's just play four
player what are you talking about Z's
leaving I'm I have no choice like
Heather Patrick's my
ride it's only 2 a.m. you don't have
work
tomorrow regardless it's only 2: a.m.
you don't have work tomorrow I have work
at 8:00 dude really yeah oh my God B
pulling it all nigh or is what I do work
in a [__] kitchen it doesn't
we we
bail we've been here for what 4 hours wa
tomorrow or something man there's always
another day what is it a car yeah we
could or we could play another game are
you really that butt hurt right now do
you want to keep playing bro
Hans let's play another game I know like
what's the big deal let's do it Patrick
if you have eight work at 8 in the
morning I don't want it's already too I
have work in 6 hours no wait Hans hold
on Heather yeah
vote give us a a yes or Patrick go y
[__] you that one Asian kid 1997 bro
1997 you're an [__]
dude what are you [__] 24 years old
grow up bro he made a screen name right
when he was
[Laughter]
born you guys he he's proud of his uh
1997 I'm the most 1997 kid ever I was
born then I was more 97 than I am oh my
gosh uh we could put money on it that
would make the game more interesting I
agree with that Ione a good amount of
money tonight that would keep everyone
in you guys want to Hans you have coffee
coffee if we put money in do you not
know this house well I'll look around
for some liquor and coffee technically I
we'll replace the liquor we we steal
from the woman whose house we're in
behave like the raccoon that I know you
sure you don't want to play
yeah all right Asian kid I'll give it to
you what are he saying he said he loves
me Christopher Casto is still here dude
get a [__] life bro what are you
doing Chris do you have work in the
morning loyal listen to Christopher get
a life dude Christopher Castle has been
here since the beginning it's so what
are you doing bro what are you doing
dude yeah this is Chris Castle no it's
Christopher Casto God my newest follower
on Instagram yo everybody go follow me
on Instagram Packard deari God damn
watch that latest uh I did a I did a uh
a 15minute comedy set on eight tabs of
acid yeah you were booked for eight my
Instagram and uh after you do that
follow adult kiddo that's Heather adult
kiddo adult kiddo Heather's Instagram
handle she's a good follow we're good
followers she's a really funny person I
just posted a picture of my dog rally
God I like that a r it's my new [__]
nickname dude we're just plugging our
own [__] this is terrible yeah this just
all the podcast is dude it's that it's
dead air and then it's just hey follow
me wait I don't want to put in that much
effort that was awesome I'm proud of
that I wish you I wish put your ass to
the mic dude that was great just do it
outside next time swiggy do you know
swiggy there's a guy in the Austin
comedy scene named swiggy yeah he was on
kill Tony oh was he is that what you're
referencing swiy yeah dude everyone Lov
swiggy though I can't how do you guys
feel about some intro comedians mainly
on Kil Tony saying the most crude taboo
thing to get a laugh is it a cheap way
into comedy or is that just the name of
the game if it's funny it's funny who
gives a [__] I don't know yeah what do
you mean you go do it dude intro
comedians what do you
mean what does that mean intro
comedians Derek is a nasty all right
come on guys come on fellas Derek is a
nasty man
swiy y are swiy fans huh have y'all seen
my kill
Tony I was on the that Joe Rogan episode
you know that one can you talk about
something
interesting Bill Gates molested me when
I was 6 years old all right now we're
getting somewhere for the last 2 hours
he put an apple in my
mouth okay like did he roast you like a
pig I can't hear you did he put you in
like a spike of wood and just [__] you
in the ass yeah he plug the USB into my
[__] Teddy did you squeal like a
pig no you
did huh yeah we're playing yeah we're
going to play another game
down hey look around make coffee yeah no
way down for sure can I really yeah you
guys being so tired is making this a
real [__] show it's 2: in the
morning yeah it's when we typically you
know are still awake get some sleep the
rally God will'll keep it up guys don't
worry Hans King the rally God we'll keep
this
going we got Hans K and the rally God H
and the rally God bro we're going to
keep this going we're going to keep this
going all night give you an 8 Hour
podcast so you can listen to it through
your workday not feel so alone I know
you're co-workers don't want to listen
to
you I trapped a coworker recently and I
felt [__] awful about it this older
black woman I work with did you rape her
it was her first it was her first time
talking to me and she was like Hey I'm
[__] Denise or whatever if anybody
know Patrick's a rapist that's awful but
uh she was introducing herself to me and
she was like how are you doing I was
like oh I've just
been I just trapped her in a 24-minute
conversation and just order pizza I
could tell by the end of the
conversation she was like yeah I'm I'm
over this and she went back to the front
and she's never talked to me since I was
like 3 weeks ago she every time she
walked by me now she's like hi and she
puts her head down and I'm like ah and
he a word of what you just said that's
fine it was just for the it was just for
the viewers just for the listeners we're
here for the viewers
yes huh tomorrow Sunday yeah why do you
work because I took a week
off so I picked up some extra shifts I
make no money guys I work a regular 9
to5 so drop some money donate donate
some money in the
chat calling it shuffling it oh yes ah
for a minute there I was upset I was
like ah we're calling it what am I going
to do in this podcast stand I just go
back to my regular life I'm somebody
today I'm just going to go eat a
rotisserie chicken in my bedroom by
myself
nak I don't want to do that [__] SLA
yourself in minut yeah [__] hot sauce
[__] early bird hot
sauce so there's a bowl game and the the
loser or the winner of the bowl game had
to get a bucket like a Gatorade bucket
of mayonnaise dumped on them oh I hate
that Duke's May too
duk's Mayo is a thick bow game it was a
bowl game yeah like college football oh
a bowl
game yeah not a Chicago bowls game yeah
I was like what a bowl game dude your
accent is so thick you don't know what a
thick Texas accent is you have like a
really bad one no I don't I have a very
normal I sound very
normal yeah hey can I can you load a
bowl
w i don't sound like where where's your
family from Gareth are they all from
Austin yeah they're all from Austin uh
and Houston
Houston playing again yeah you want to
play would you be upset if
I please go do that please go do that
Heather go make yourself be more upset
if you threw up anywhere
else go outside would you be upset if I
threw up like an appropriate human being
with decent see I grew up in Austin Zach
but my family's from here in
Houston now if you're from Houston and
you're from like the South part of
Houston that you are the H has turned
into y's so if you meet somebody that
has a really thick Houston or Texan
accent they're going to be like I'm from
Houston it's straight up Houston there's
no h just why that's all it is so I
don't have a thick ACC thick
accent do you have um Dean's got a
dent I lived in San Diego for two years
now that I
believe yeah I would have to tell people
that I was from Texas and then they
would it was this unoriginal California
[__] should ever they would be like
oh you know there's only two things from
Texas steers and queers and I don't see
any horns on you and every single person
said that it's like like uh the comedy
or the comedians talking about me being
looking like Adam Divine that's why I'm
telling you Patrick you're better than
that like you came up with a great I
said it because you said that
everyone you said you look like a
average white man a generic white man
and I said right like Adam Divine
because we talked about the Adam Divine
comment before and I said right that's
why everyone calls you Adam Divine
no I wasn't I wasn't saying oh you look
like Adam devant I was saying yeah he
used it as a [__] bird and it's just
know it's bad yeah because the viewers
hadn't heard it before than that the
viewers hadn't heard it before they got
they got uh added the best one for me
said that it looked like all of the Two
and a Half Men combined and then did he
punch a woman in the face I think
Zack yeah and then Zach I think uh had a
really was it you Zack I pretty it's
either you or Brian McDuffy had a really
good one it was like you look exactly
like a Bob's Burgers character too yeah
I was like damn super accurate those are
the two super accurate this is the money
I'm throwing on the game a dollar a
dollar that dollar bill for the game I
have money but this is what we're doing
this is what we're doing does anybody
have a dollar want to put in on it I'll
venmo it I'll venmo a dollar how about
five bucks let's just make it five let's
make it a dollar I don't have any cash
well then any want a dollar whatever we
I think we can all trust each other for
it's a $4 game $4 bow you can profit
$3 I like those I've never won a game so
I'm okay with that but it's a solid bet
for
me if this was like sound a lot
different with the headphones on yeah
you can hear everything it's crazy yeah
like the wind did y'all hear the fart
really well oh amazingly oh my God great
that was a solid fart my mom uh made
split pea soup Burger's character is
pretty good that wasn't me I would I
would be proud of that no yeah well you
I don't know man I'm pretty sure it was
Brian McDuffy but it was you have like
no upper lip and no Chin yeah yes there
you go
butd
I [__] hate you you piece of [__]
dude you look like you have Lego
hair
leg I need to get a haircut need to get
a haircut
come y ever gotten a facial before I
have a nose
job you have a nose job I got a rhino
plus to here damn you are Jewish man
[__] weren't woring about are there
any before pictures uh yeah I shattered
my nose that's why I got surgery you
might as well get yeah yeah it wasn't
for it wasn't like I didn't like my nose
I uh I my cousin had a really big nose
bur up and apparently she got made fun
and she got a nose job one time I yelled
at her that she had a big nose and it
really hurt her feelings wasn't cool
nice yeah that's hilarious oh so
funny damn
thanks you ain't going to be that
dude five I didn't you're right G's
going first I'm definitely going first
I'm red I'm assuming okay oh yeah this
this this does suck for the
glare never
noticed it's only from this
angle the
glare talking about Zach's
glare I don't see it you don't see that
get a little close oh there we go yeah
it's bad you can't see [__] yeah just
move your head off center oh
yeah
guys got
you got you
brother man yeah you can hear everything
I'm [__] sorry viewers I guess if
you're watching on a laptop or a TV go
to the bathroom you're
fine Oh Daddy
Heather are you all right she's in the
bathroom she's cool she's [__]
Heather is taking be pooping dudee
Heather be pooping she's so cool your
turn you know what Zach you're an idiot
that was really mean we've just been
joking around but that was pretty
offensive bring up the chat on the
laptop I hope it was we'll get to it
appropriately this time no we
[Music]
won't you can't help but stare it gives
us it's something to talk about
to how you feeling Heather are you all
right huh are you all right hun ran away
to check the restroom is what you coming
to join the game his home grab an IPA
from the fridge everything's okay
Heather's thr it
up Heather threw it
up I got
drunk did you hey I love you Heather
I'll play I [__] it get in here we've
already set up for four players at this
point you can jump in but Hans is going
to be hey how many viewers in the chat
just let us
know can I steal hans's seat go for
it you know stop stop it stop it Zach
stop I'll make my [__] move when you
stop
it all right stop what what I fro
Up Make Your Move
Gareth someone said I was eating in the
bathroom [__] off dude she was we that's
so mean she'd rather tell you she was
brown girl wasted that's okay I'm half
Brown I'm more like beige why do we have
to get I'm more Brown than
others 39 million viewers H that's not
bad here the thing I didn't eat today I
had better numbers I wish it was a
little more up than that I didn't eat
and and then I drink a lot don't ask us
question how the Twinkies that's so mean
how are the Twinkies in the
bath they were making fat joke the whole
time come on man he doesn't attacked me
at all thank you that makes me
know attack been debate between us for
three
years I'm [__] again dare probably
because he's a small man Heather never
gets laid that's his problem I am a
small guy I haven't gotten laid in so
fck [__] long dude
Patrick look at Heather right now that's
a lie look at you I already know the
truth of that hello dth do you think his
name is Darth everybody I've already
done over this yeah it's your turn
[__] Derek likes Heather Gareth likes
what does that mean what does it wait
who cares who cares he okay sorry just
stop reading
it what color am I
you're not play who at this table do you
think has [__] if you can
just I had sex with Patrick I literally
damn it Gareth you were supposed to let
them guess bro why do you think Gareth
knew I was on
grinder I look gay but I'm not that I
didn't he's not gay I'm just we're just
two straight men in a sexual
relationship I went to school for uh
digital marketing where did my other
hair tie go I graduated
come lad wait where did
[Music]
oh oh Hans Heather wants to play now
yeah I want to play went to school for
film it's not working out wants to play
now so do we change the board and
everything is moved oh wait yeah you no
I'll just hang out it doesn't matter I
don't have to play yeah just hang out no
I want to hear uh hans's rort we can add
her in yeah let's do it be here no cuz
then you have to change the whole board
it's okay only two of us have gone and I
I won the first round so it doesn't mean
anything I'm always
losing votes to let Heather in I do give
it to the chat zero for no one for yes
[__] you Patrick nobody loves you give
it to the follow black people on
Instagram don't put that [__] on me now
you know not to like her for that uh
whatever uh makes this
faster I'm a tired boy oh that's not the
correct answer it's only two more hours
it's not I you
want yeah we already voted yes no just
play two of us did you didn't see his
hand his hand came up all right it'll be
easy it'll be easy let's do it quick no
just play No we're going to add you in
Heather you can't know I'm not taking
that as a [__] answer just don't
change the board just add to it no we
have to add to don't change the board
just add to it we have to add to it
that's what he said he said don't said
add to it remember the part where he
said add to
it shut up I'm blue this time everybody
I'm almost sad Patrick doesn't win
unless he's
red that's why I won the last two games
back your
settl take that your
sett Zach just have a good time oh I'm
just so tired do you have any Patrick's
driving me home thank you for go outside
go to the patio having everybody home
Zach really doesn't like it when I touch
him like this
thanks and I think that he's homophobic
and that's
why my love language is not
being a lot of zeros oh it's from the
same guy I see you really don't like it
when I touch you I don't actually like
being touched that much in general it's
cuz I'm homophobic it's cuz you don't
get laid a lot true it was Zero for no
one for yes I got to stop doing that I'm
apologizing the one's one legit for real
the one's one y'all want to keep
watching how many viewers 38 right now
pretty [__] good dude shut up Patrick
38 human beings are watching us 38 human
beings in the world don't have a life
anybody watching with somebody Patrick
you wased imagine watching this [__] you
wash dishes Patrick that's what I do I
wash dishes 38 people Des heard that
okay so I'm a prep cook shut up it goes
up live I'm a prep cook I make soy sauce
all day so that people can watch it
after it's uploaded so it really doesn't
matter [__] yeah dude that's cool I
don't like really cool are you telling
me Hans that most people that watch this
won't be reading these comments and our
conversation will make no sense upon no
you can pull up the you can pull up the
live stream com yeah the live chat what
is happening you got to be young you got
to know how to use the [__] internet
even I was like when I was watching my
kill Tony back I was like how the [__]
do you pull chat I couldn't figure it
out at all are you talk like a cough
button did y'all go watch living with
his bed what's going
on shut up anybody anybody in the chat
if you've found someone dead in your
life or someone you love died in a
tragic way let us know we'll read about
it we'll talk about it have you guys
ever like had a tragic loss in your life
what's the most tragic loss you guys
have had in your
life death wise not relationship wise
that's gay Patrick what happened to you
was a child I was molested when I was 6
years old by my neighbor she was nine so
I don't count it I don't blame her
sounds awesome did you feel hurt no it's
weird because I think what happened is
she walked in on her parents doing it a
lot cuz they probably did it when they
they probably did it with the door open
a lot cuz they were pill heads did you
come so she would just watch it and be
like oh that's what happens you know
that's what you do so we would have play
dates and to her play dates were like oh
go down on me did you come yeah that
sounds awesome I never came now I just
for 2 years I went down on my neighbor
when I was six to when I was about eight
that's fun yeah at what age that bad
that good I don't know it made me a
comedian said you like tiny Asian girls
I'm so sorry I'm a thick Hispanic you
got it wrong Patrick is very molest well
thank you that's I think I kind of
[__] you up
maybe well now I all I do is molest kids
so but you were a kid when it happened
you guys I was a wicked
he isn't joking about that they wanted
posters around town there's been a
missing child sign around town lately
that's been like I see it every day I
walk to work it's where is she where is
she it's like a 17-year-old kid where is
she it's a 17-year-old kid and when it's
a 17-year-old kid I think man he went on
like a grinder date or some [__] he went
on like a Craigslist gay date you know
something like that that's the only type
of thing that like that's when you go
missing you're 17 you go on grinder and
you're like or you go on Craigslist and
you're like I'm hiding from the world
hey stranger 47 can you [__] [__] me
at a bus stop and then they murder them
drag their dead body away who wants to
get [__] in a bus stop that's awes
young kids who are scared and don't know
how to do it and they go on the
internet oh my God I know this from
experience that someone that's murdered
many
uh many a lonely twink so major if y'all
don't understand this a majority of
people um in the Austin Texas Community
scene are pedophiles and they murder the
children when they're done uh mainly
Zach and Patrick and my friend
Antonio do you have any rort no no rort
no that was accurate
10 I play with
that I thought going to be one of those
things for like something is going to
come out from some of the scene and then
they're going to cut together like they
knew they knew Patrick was M it's going
to become a thing that if you got
molested it was it's a bad thing you're
you're a bad
person what' I get I can't see it is
terrible seven
seven what everyone else get I got nine
[__]
got seven seven what did I get eight
Patrick what the [__] did you get I got
seven
four four Heather I don't remember what
I got Heather got nine you got no
wait what did Hans get group chat there
either eight or 10 you got eight all
right I remember you got eight everybody
else had a seven at highest so should
had a nine oh then Heather is the
champion I guess Fargo North Dakota
shout
out something
happen
anyway yeah the Greek in the cave
there's not a Greek comic here there is
not a single Greek comedian in the scene
so now we are going into uh 230 Katon
wait is it 245 at this
point this is uh what we
do and I've never won a
game not once where yall watching from
let us know no is anybody else going to
call in from the Hans
hotline that was fun before Patrick just
started [__] hanging up on people
yeah before I started making it funny no
that
guy that guy was going to tell us you
put this on the 694
there is the guy that called in on
mushroom is okay if you're still on the
chat please let us know Patrick's an
[__] no h put it towards the four
what about New
Hampshire's North it says it says North
Korea Heather it's a good
show yo htown one love baby UGK for life
oh New Hampshire foa face is watching
from New
Hampshire
oh open m come thday great open one of
the best H one of the best in America I
feel like like you're ly Hans rolled a
10 no he [__] didn't yet no Hans he
rolled an eight I was here um whose turn
is it it's uh gareth's Gareth it's your
turn thank
you y'all know how Katan works by the
way I would [__] hate to be watching
this [__] if I didn't know how K Works
cuz we're not explaining it we're just
playing while we hang
out so did you like lose
self-explanatory it's self-explanatory
what do you a [__] idiot you don't
just get
it Edmonton Canada wow hey I'm in your
mother's room she's dead in
there it do they can you not put the box
down I'm sorry dude I apologize I didn't
even realize there was the box that we
need stop play playing huh you wanted to
play we changed the whole board for you
I said you guys didn't have to but you
wanted me I hate you so much he if you
back out of this I swear to God I'm not
she's definitely not she's in it for the
long long ha we're playing K what the
[__] Zach's going to be the one that Ops
out God damn it Zach drink a coffee
bro how do you guys get your
coffee
black really yeah that makes sense
that's why you're fit that's the way to
do it that's I used to love black coffee
I just can't do it anymore no I don't I
never have put anything in my I don't
know once in a while I'll get like a
thing at Starbucks that's like a I just
like look like I'm getting an ice cream
that has caffeine you know I'll get a
dessert that's what yeah that's what you
get your feet are cold should we turn on
the heat no I'm
fine whose turn is it what's going on
it's mine GTH come on dude yell at
everyone all night to go and then when
you go it takes 7,000 hours you're not
paying I already know where I'm going I
know where I'm going to go I know it's
like you go here I'm genius thank you so
much is there like a kill Tony should we
watch all of
our fun please no if it wasn't for the
headphones dear God no all I'm
sorry oh my God old Brew on average
watching 55 seconds that makes sense you
go to Starbucks get blonde espresso it's
so good Hans never explains Katan it
makes sense he doesn't he just doesn't
do it it's cuz Hans is also a pedophile
how long have we been going
for four hours yo six seven bucks we've
made that's like a$ do10 each you can
keep
it that's surprising coming from the Jew
that's
insane well I mean I guess that's him
being like I have money I don't need
it he feels bad for
us are we pulling watch Z Overman set
dude W kill Tony clip huh really did not
make this no [__]
way with Shane Gilly I did not make this
clip who made this Shane Gilly sucks at
comedy bro what an unfunny [__] Shane
what an [__] no I'm kidding that's
crazy I'm not kidding I hate Shane
Gillis to my
core I'm kidding I like Shan Gillis A
lot can we just watch the comedy and not
the
interview I want to find out how awkward
I am let's only watch the interview
they've playing four hours let get right
to the
interview hey if you guys are uh God I
hate you if you guys are following this
put on the uh have you have you been on
Kil Tony we're all watching the Zack
Silverman kill Tony Set uh episode
491 oh you follow David Lucas too yeah
man there couldn't be any more of a
different human being yeah to David
Lucas than you I wish I I didn't hear
them say this I would have like done
David Lucas's joke or something he has
been at like any kill Tony stuff lately
no he's bigger than that now he's
better he's above it even though he's
not
[Music]
for real the old band does r look at
look at Zach with his shaved face he
looks so good like a little leopard
gecko come to
life Christian I'm a bad Christian I
drink I'm
aw I'm
bad a year ago I've gotten better at
shenas hates
you in an embarrassment
[Music]
way Shang is laughing at how bad you are
he's you're not doing bad but you're so
nervous hear the so nervous yeah I was
super
[Music]
nervous Tony like that
my other set was so much
better it's funny cuz the other set you
look man manlier in the other set you
have the goatee right no the next set no
oh you don't I just have a little beard
oh okay but I mean it's almost a year
later I'm bigger face you look like a
[__]
kid you look like you're straight out of
high school and [__] yeah that's crazy
oh yeah I was sick too they like called
me out for looking pale I was like I've
never gotten that and then I got that
night I went home and
puked yeah I like had food poisoning or
something you ate a wheat then you were
like yeah like I was like what are they
talking
about ah we're going to get there we're
going to get there we're we're all going
why youing your what right here I don't
know just tab
it hey if you guys listen to this if you
guys could lose an arm or be blind which
would you rather lose both arms or be
blind both arms arms or be blind what
would you rather arms arms you get
Prosthetics all right if you could lose
both arms or both legs which would you
rather arms
legs what do why you prothetic yeah
wheelchair [__] I don't know all right
if you could all right you could go
skiing still with legs who gives a [__]
you can go skiing without leg people in
the chairs it's [__] sick also like I
don't looks [__] tight I don't SK I
use my arms every
day if you could lose your hearing or
your sight which would you
choose hearing or your sight hearing or
your
sight hearing you're crazy if you would
pick
site so
much oh this is the chat for Kil Tony I
thought it was I was like holy [__] bro
like 10,000 people are watching right
now
that's
funny dude I I watched the live chat of
my kill Tony episode and everyone just
went foa
foaa just calling me fat I was like okay
cool every when I went on everybody in
the chat was like this kid's going to
murder somebody one day can't wait to
read the headlines about this kid one
day murdering somebody I was like rather
I don't have can they also see true or
can the only our set as well was the
watching our sets right now no it's
funny because I was when we were
watching Zach set and he was insecure
about it I was like Zach shut up but
then if you pulled up my set right now
it' be like ah we don't have to watch
this pull up my set pull up my kill Tony
set kill Tony uh 200 I think or 400 kill
Tony 400 with Joe
Rogan you can just go to my my YouTube
page I have it clipped on
there um you're nervous Nancy
myself it's weird when you walk on stage
and you look at them in person you're
like holy [__] that's [__]
weird Joe rogi In the
Flesh Patrick with three
KS there it
is on your YouTube channel that's why
it's blurry in a shitty video my bad I
didn't know I had no [__] idea until
now you playing is it my turn I had no I
had no idea the quality was Jack
[__] is it my turn now no it is your
turn don't forget to take your resources
wait how do you already have a [__]
settlement
though Monday who has more funay us I
pulled another name out of the bucket he
go by the name
of
Patrick have you gone like find the
episode
[Music]
jeez so
good the band is [__]
great what did your roll I didn't roll
anything I placed my
second who the was last I'm so confused
next I I just went what do you mean I
just went just to place your last wasn't
it supposed to go no it's your last
settl so I need bre and I need my
contacto is mother I'm kidding of course
okay I deleted my mother's contact info
as soon as she
died yes it is true my mother did die
not the worst loss though you know one L
four to Georg line fan in the
world yeah she always said you're going
to be the death of me and then my father
was the one to forget to Med wrong again
[__] [__]
[Music]
hat know all right go ahead Heather time
to go I got a weat a sheep St
[__] thanks
ended Myself by calling my own dead
mother a
[Laughter]
[__] that's funny I think that's
funny wow somebody's just making clips
of this [__] that's [__] cool hey
capitalize the [__] p in my name
would
you this is way better
quality this is the same episode though
oh it's episode 490 that I'm on whose
turn is it
is it your turn this is such good
quality I had so much more hair back
there what happened to me dude what
happened to this game I'm so confused
you got to roll it's your turn Heather
roll I go yeah you're first oh I am look
at me and Joe Rogan 3 feet away it's so
weird three Hans is 3 feet away from Joe
Rogan all the [__] time is that weird
to
you opening for Joe Rogan yeah I hate
when people were like nah they're just
another person it's like yeah but
they're a person that you like admired
for a long time and now you're watching
them what' you r i was that found and I
tried did
I what
[Music]
see Joey Diaz found his mother dead in
his kitchen when he was on acid so me
and Joey Diaz share that [__] which is
cool
you can
go she was sick for a while and then my
dad your mom should
go I wasting
hang
um
wow uh does anyone have any
wood no I don't have any
wood2 awesome man godamn so good for 22
how long you been doing what a
compliment thank you
Tony
sheep I did start on 911 that was my
first time ever doing standup comedy was
on
911 what wood I got for a brick for what
for a
brick I don't have wheat but I'll give
you a brick for a
wood brick or wood or a sheep for
[Music]
wheat
oh
good this a good
joke that's a good
joke there was one comment in the chat
that said that test the soil joke was
decent and I was like thank you nobody
appreciated it it's a good joke because
oshit would have great soil because of
the 6 million dead in the ground amazing
soil like the best
soil they didn't all die in outtz no but
a lot you know the the mass Graves there
it wasn't 6 million in Aus I know I
know it was I well I know what you're
saying that was it it never happened at
all I get that what number it
was does anybody have a rock they want
to trade me you refuse to cut your
hair brick or
sheep [__] the chats
dude dud Joe Rogan doesn't talk during
my set at all everyone in the chat's
like Joe Rogan doesn't like this kid at
all it's like people were like does like
and I was
like
oh you did fine have you been
on yeah a great I was on aode oh yeah
they called me up on stage oh yeah yeah
yeah
six what did you guys
r i ha what did
you my okay I haven't pay attention
Gareth what did you roll what number
strong I'm sorry Gareth what number did
you roll what number did you
roll I was so long ago Dude Zach what
number did you roll I don't remember
dude really [__] I wasn't paying
attention you can go Gareth all
right get heather can you pass me the
dice
yeah sorry oh it's okay uh episode 514
I do a much better set get back to the
then no I'm going after hun what is
he hey you you tried doing comedy
Zachary Bennett it's [__] hard to
know what to do with your hand
bro I'm autistic I don't know what the
[__] to do I literally just the other
day I did a set and I put my hand like
this at a point cuz I'm a [__] I felt it
like being stiff by my side and I put it
I put it like this H spread them I made
fun of it but in the moment I felt
[__]
stupid message retracted what the [__]
did you say
dude message retracted he said the
[__] nword dude
probably somebody type the nword into
the chat cuz I just want to see if it
pops up you
won't I don't know if YouTube like uh
what's a it's my turn no well I know you
have the option to like
uh turn off like offensive comments and
[__] but yeah I turned that off that you
can allow them wait what did you you can
say whatever you want right somebody
type the N word in the chat I mean if
you're a black guy if you're an nword
you can just you can just comment the
nword I have a
job yeah I don't do that well black
people are the
nword that's
why you know black people
are oh my God referred to as the nword
that's why they get to no one likes this
that's why because black people go I can
say it because um's like what you're an
nword yeah
nword um so what do you guys you say
Edward mhm I was talking about Twilight
we do another
uh I think someone type the N word and
it says message reacted oh really okay
good straight up doesn't allow the nword
in chat no that guy looks like he typed
out message
retracted actually yeah that's funny oh
yeah my turn you guys
yeah
eight what episode was Heather on I
don't remember I think it was like
525 if that's a what' you roll
eight eight oh hell yeah give me that
sheep
[__] now I know why you were doing so
bad it sucks with the glare six yeah
it's
horrible two
rocks thank
you who wants sheep for what wheat no I
wheat brick dick a hole when you talk
about the dude I just up I don't need it
literally every resource wait you want
to give me give me a wood and a wheat
sheep who wants
sheep what show me what you got to do no
how the [__] would I do that give me
that show you what I have I'm trying to
take a peek dude no you you better who
wants sheep I don't even get that
comment who wants
Rock
um y I'll take a rock for what say it
five more [__] times
what about a rock and a sheep for a w
cut it out rad
Lord no it's not that wood and a wheat
type something else wood or brick kick
radl Lord out of the chat give we block
kick him the [__] out of the chat joking
if you can kick him out of the chat
that's [__]
funny that's time
out Hans type the N word into the chat
I'm not saying no I'm
kidding oh my
god um it's late as [__] it's okay well
that's just for this one time we started
game at 5: in the morning or was it 4
it's not delayed as [__] it's delayed by
like a minute [__]
out H's of course one we have a
beautiful color scheme going oh it's my
turn how do you have so many cards
no one wants brick or no one wants sheep
or Rock I'll give you a brick for a
sheep two sheep I'll give you a brick
for two sheep what about a wood I don't
have a wood a wheat give me wheat and
for two this all I have is Brick for
what what about wood or wheat or yeah
I'll give you a brick for those I don't
have anything else wood and a wheat for
this I
wish I'll give you a brick for two sheep
one
two one two three
four
okay can I get a bit of that
nine God damn it dude
[__]
nine thank you anybody have any
Wheat oh give you so much for
wheat I will give you brick or rock for
a
weat it's my turn you have wheat don't
yes you do I saw it in your
hand
um [__] fine
dude
all
right two lucky number two anybody have
a two oh [__] yeah I got We There You
Go anybody have a rock I'll give you a
brick for a
rock I'll give you a brick for a rock a
rock okay give me my water
watercup
all right Gareth it's your turn uh roll
for how it works you can't roll for
people it's IL give me one second part
of the game bro it's part of the game
literally the only thing you have to
do drop a zero if you're enjoying this
podcast and drop a one
you hate this
[Music]
podcast you don't even know how to spell
zero oh
you a zero if you're hating it one if
you're Madam zerone up a
hill is that a h reference yes he said a
two also is r in my period of
absence Michael in a prop comic what are
you talking about droing
zero is that cuz you put Madam zerone up
a hill what's happening it's because
your mother's a [__] it's Gareth get it
right you
idiots okay I'm going to build a city
and my
turn watching there you
go that's how you do it wait I haven't
seen this movie in so what did Gareth
roll uh I rolled an eight yes give me a
sheepy
better yeah
you what's what's y'all's favorite
Disney movie oh good question I would
have to say uh well I like some weird
ones I like ruli a lotes any you know
what I've never very good is a Pixar
Disney yeah um [__] does anyone want
to trade a stone for a brick you have
the stone I have the brick I'll do it
for weat I have I have a brick I would
like to trade for I Stone no I can't do
that I did I wish I didn't do the trade
with you go ahead um I really liked that
uh the soul movie that came out recently
that was really good I haven't seen it
that was really [__] good um but it's
good if it's Disney they did a lot they
made a lot of [__] movies I don't
know if you right well I used to love uh
[__] what's that movie uh there for me
though you in the middle
holes I'm always in the middle of holes
you've seen him all
right anybody else what's your favorite
Disney movie
um Star Wars wow what a yeah Technic
Star Wars is a Disney movie technically
Every Act or uh [__] movie is an action
or Disney movie Avengers Avers yeah The
Simpsons was [__] tight though The
Simpsons Movie dude The Simpsons want
any of these
cards no I'll give you a brick for trade
do not trade with him I'll give you a
brick for two sheep I can't do anything
for that I don't like that he's showing
us his cards and aat this isn't don't
for two sheep I don't have a weat not do
it I'll give you a brick for two sheep
brick
okay you guys remember uh Xenon girl of
the 21st century what a great that movie
[__] r
yeah that movie [__] ruled
dude Xenon girl of the 21st century I
remember it I don't really it was a
great Disney movie I remember that one
movie with the geese i r the five do you
know what I'm talking about with the
geese yeah or wait no no no the Canadian
goose no I don't remember that where
they they like find like a pack of like
Canadian geese and they likeit rescue
them back to he and this girl like
builds like a flying
machine and they they're like yeah and
then she's like the leader of the pack
it's [__] sick dud dude how tight
would that be if you were the leader of
the pack of Canadian geese they like you
are our leader and you just had to fly
with him that's so tight a bunch of GE
just going he he be better be the leader
of gee oh I Ru the
geese Luck of the Irish that's a great
movie look of the Irish is a good one
what was the last one a little racist
towards Irish people like genuinely like
the family is like we've hid this from
you for so long but we're [__] Irish
is gangs in New York Disney M now I
don't oh I mean yeah I guess now if
maybe maybe it is now I don't count
anybody we they want to
trade which also holds this is a this is
some has some racis rock shoot for two
weeks about they kill the black dude
because they're like that white woman
kissed the black dude and
they it puts a curse on their land yeah
puts a curse on the land and they kill
the black dude which is really weird for
a Disney movie don't they grow some
sweet
assy
six ohu [__] off you
six [__] [__] all right you can go
Gareth I Hate Everything hey Hans give
me those ties Hans May thank
you
D what did you i r a
five does anyone have a a stone what did
you roll H that was three turns for what
wait for what does he don't have a stone
for what what do you got what do you
want for what I want a stone but what
what do you I want a wood actually no I
can't I want a a wood I don't have a
wood all right then all right damn was H
what did you roll Zach wait
10 wait was this a racially
charged they killed the black dude
because the white woman kissed him sh
Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait no I
I tra not only kissed them not only
kissed him the white woman was in love
with them they take him out on a boat
they shoot him in the back of the head
it's [__] up H my yeah you got it I'm
only doing it cuz it's my piece who the
face thanks for clarifying that
Hans just to let everybody know you're
not a genuine person who just [__]
wanted to pick it up cuz it was your
property six God Dam
it I'm even I'm getting sick of
it
I have a six and I'm over have a city on
a
six I hope they roll a seven God I hope
I roll a
seven look this is when they killed the
black dude oh they ride up on him look
at that man as a kid that [__] me up
as a kid that [__] me up no she was so
hot though when she was like kissing
people and killing
them sexual Awakening much nine n God
damn Patrick Patrick's killing in this
game oh I am
too oh
wait he wanted to call me out to throw
you guys off you know how Sly he
is anybody have a
wheat it's such a tale of American
malens and the crimes of her
past shut
up then the Triumph at Return of the
white man to save the black man and the
goodness in all of
us and then later in the movie shy lauff
shows up and he goes I don't know why
but I hate you
zero and then also zero gets arrested
for stealing the black and then it's
like mostly black kids in the in the
thing it's a pretty [__] a racist
dude wrote this movie dude a why did you
kill
him how did she feeling she's just being
cool don't worry about it she was just
being police officer
sick actually I don't PR that she's
killing racist
she's she's an ally oh did she murder a
racist that's cool
that's oh and then they hang her right
does she have the poisonous lipstick or
whatever yeah no she dies in the desert
remember remember it's been she she
drinking that like honey or whatever oh
so splooge it's hot
splooge yeah she does drink splooge why
they call it splooge she just di
drinking
come that's how all women
die this is also child
slavery it really is child this is what
made sense to children they're like oh
yeah can imagine that happening guys
don't look too hard into the the
criminal justice system
there that's definitely how adult
are that makes a lot of sense what's
that actor's name right
there
John
John John Jacob Jingleheimer Schmid John
the racist name name
too wait what was R 11 [__] called
out idiot yeah I'm sorry that was
completely my fault it was good point $5
on this game by the way really everybody
threw a dollar no everybody threw a
dollar
in so it's a $5 bet it's a $5 pool you
don't have a look at that that's five
that's five black kids right there it's
mostly black kids that's probably
not that's a little much my turn wait I
have an 11 wait iude dude it's it's
black kids in Mex kids and then
Shuff that's a little [__] up that's
super accurate and Shuff is only there
because he was set up wa what did you
roll Gareth 11
11 shab buff is in Peak form all right
just comedic and yet so hot you guys
ever watch the movie Disturbia it's such
a [__] up
movie Disturbia that's because it's
based off of a old Hitchcock
movie distur Disturbia is a [__] movie
and it's Hitchcock movie is actually
good it's [__] up because shyu stalks
his neighbor his hot female neighbor he
just stalks her watches her through her
window and just like it's weird and then
she like falls in love with him and at a
point he like he ruins her party by
playing music out of his because he's
getting jealous that she's talking he's
a psychopath in the movie and
then skinny yo go watch [__]
Disturbia that movie is [__] up like
really watch that [__] distur is [__]
up dude no and we looked up who directed
it and they're both a bunch of [__]
ugly [__] SS yeah dude ugly white
Sims is anyone all toy [__] off dude who
put that there anyone like an
Altoid who has I'll take an Altoid who
has
a
we I'll trade you wood for
wheat come on I don't have one he what
was give me a weat I'll give you wood I
don't know what was rolled six six all
right I'm going to build a
road
[Music]
guess [__] bu right there well yeah
right
there
um this guy's so cucked by that woman oh
yeah dude he scratches her and he walks
around with that scratch on his face
hold yeah did y'all know that that girl
Jess that does comedy has a
husband and she's just like openly like
wants people to [__] her with her
husband watching really yes this is
going out live so please don't say
anything stupid 10 you [__] idiot
we're talking about something have you
ever heard of that person who everybody
respects
sorry like who is
it I want to meet her five oh hell yeah
[__] so she say it on stage yeah she
did and bottom line it was really cool
thanks for making me feel awkward about
it but it was really cool she was being
well then say her name because if she on
stage just yeah know but it was it was
cool and I was like well wait hold on is
he here right now and he was like yeah
right here well well then [__] off say
your name who cares don't say your name
now it has bad intent [__] off dude Hans
just like making me think about I'm not
cheating this time your I've rolled a
seven
oh terrible yeah I mean it's just a
great movie oh I need to get my [__]
scratched
he plays the Dad and Ray Donovan right
you ever see Ray Donovan yes it's a good
[__] show oh I got my phone to look
up that hold this thing hold on yeah
what else are you going to Google not
Google women who let their women who get
[__] in front of their hus so I'm
looking up Disturbia and then no
actually we don't want to hear that
that's not like no we already talked
about the Disturbia [__] you got to
watch it to like you got to like watch
it you got to see it
the whole movie is like
insane um well yeah cuz it's a it's it's
a Hitchcock it's based off a Hitchcock
film I didn't even know that what which
Hitchcock film that's what I'm trying to
figure out right now oh
okay and that's it's a much better movie
10 again
[__]
10 does anybody have a brick I'll give
you a sheep for a brick sheep for a
brick
all right Gareth you can go
okay this will be
better where would you like it
Hans yeah let's do it right
front
eight oh you son of a [__] who did
that will Boba I can't do nothing that's
what I'll tell
you turn bringing it
back I remember my
roots
seven four five six o I got
eight why not cheat
Zach when you jingle those it sounds
like glass smashing you you bumped it
earlier and it sounded like glass
smashed
kiss dude [__]
kiss watching
[Laughter]
or so the the Hitchcock film that
Disturbia is based off of is called rear
window and you should all watch that cuz
that's actually John movie no window
behind that's with the James Stewart
who's also in what is he in he's in
Vertigo of course but he did um what was
the show he
did
what is it we're all sheep
oh eight eight oh yeah give
me should
do um does anyone have any
brick not for you I'll trade you a lot
of stuff for
Brick
I do you want nothing what do you guys
want for Brick I have nothing dude
really I'm serious huh I have all the
same [__] you have huh I'm good [__] off
dude really yeah does anybody have any
Wheat no does anyone have any sheep no
yeah what do you want wood I'll do
that ah she murdered all them in the
town that's pretty cool I guess this
ain't a racist movie it's about race
racism trade for oh [__] Justice being
served she murdered all the shin in the
if you're going to have violence you
might as well be in a good direction
yeah she's the Kristoff wall to this
movie for a
brick and then I'll put this down she
down we
down you know um right now Spider-Man
has a better rating than
um like most hitch eight
eight doesn't holes have a better
doesn't Spider-Man have a better rating
than like any movie ever it's like
classical music
versus right now it's uh it's ranked at
number seven in the best movies of all
time in a 9. does anybody have a brick
yeah it's like does anybody have a brick
I'll give you a we versus
sh anybody have a sucks box [__]
sucks it's almost not the same art form
does anybody have a
brick I'll give you a wheat I have no
brick dude it's like Walt Chamberlain
Walt chamblin was impressive even though
he was playing a different game the fact
that he was having a 60s diet and still
able to with other malnourish
people
that's so
impressive
[__] how many cards gar shut up sorry
how many cards
Z [__] what [__] at least I get to move
the robber and steal from Heather cuz
she had to open up her mouth about it
I'm just kidding I'm going to steal from
Hans of course did you move the rubber
already no I got to disperse my payment
to the
gods
um
really what what should I do what's more
important no okay no leave it there no
you're right you're right the six is
hitting but that's just a very important
one all H spread
him don't say like
that
uh better build a city and then my
turn
go all right teach him a lesson hit back
four trying to be good
[Music]
parents those are good parents it's good
parenting that's not good to be in a
room full of kids and be like hit him
back
does anyone have
wood they were doing shitsu back then no
one's got wood I had to get rid of it
because that seven okay there you go
Huns o
sorry
n
Dam
p
she's
like like someone like a person who owns
a club around here
[__]
six [__] Rock Jesus
Christ are these my cards are these
what
should oh
he all right three
rock this mov so violent for a
[Music]
city
right because it's child
slavery the child slav investigation you
did I develop my
card you're not enslaving these children
correctly wait what was your role we
looked into it I forget wait I forget
eight we're not
ad give one two three Jesus Christ
Heather's killing at this game aren't
you glad you played
yeah seven
Jesus 2 3
four he
Heather's winning by a
lot Heather how much she oh my God how
many victory points do you have I don't
worry about the
dud po 2 3 4 5 six damn Heather and
Patrick killing in this
game she has a bunch of victory points
too you don't know does anybody does
anybody have a he has two cards does
anybody have a
uh no when was the last time you
shuffled the the what's it called deck
before we played cuz I have to do
everything around here okay I was just
asking you want to shuffle him again
development cards you grabbing the
longest road does anybody have a wood
yeah I do Patrick is longest road knock
yourself out does anybody have a
wood no no well what he has eight points
now anybody has a wood I don't all right
Gareth
here okay I'm Shuffling the
develop six dude what the [__]
man I hate that
six
okay Jesus you have to fold every one of
them I'm sorry I didn't
mean look at
that stop it on it's
rude bending my cards is really my turn
it's not your turn okay why you why are
you so
antagonistic just say it's not yet why
do you have to question me like that
like oh is it your they go to the
[__] the mountain I'm curious
nothing's happening I would say th it's
God's Thumb okay Jesus I'm buying two
development cards and I'm going to end
my it's close
enough eight eight oh baby give me them
three
sheeps all right I don't [__] someone
roll I'm to kill
[Music]
myself no put
here oh no that see USS to
[__] rock my world as a kid oh all
cuz they wanted water right and then he
crashed it into a
go try to look for
zero he's driving a car does any have
wheat no he quickly crashes the truck
into a hole I don't have no wheat cuz
there's nothing get a development card
don't spoil
it go ahead HT spoiler he dies in a car
wreck
immediately seven oh what the [__] dude
that would literally kill you can't
cheat that right there would [__]
have time to put on a seat belt and he
was completely fine dude he's completely
fine he was completely fine he would be
so [__] dead after that dude you
would be so done genuinely he would have
been so [__] yeah there would have
been uh investigation after that right
for sure Patrick your cards my card yeah
oh you are you stealing from
me to
be [__] you
dude [__] you
bro that hurts anyone want sheep no
three sheep for a brick what for a rock
three sheep for a rock three sheep for a
rock come on wait three Sheep
No about
two okay
cool wait can I have an aloid you think
he's going to you think he's going to
win and then you trade with
them
fool Foolish Game I've been saying this
forever none of y'all are listening to
me
oops
um this movie is so the story the book
is so good does
anybody it's like a really well thought
out for what
like the you want a rock yeah what do
you have you have whe Pi not to trade I
don't I'll do it for ging um here's your
wheat everybody give me your wheat okay
here you
go is that worth
it you ready to win mightbe huh oh
you yeah okay give me one
second
so much [__] wheat okay I only need
two for a development or for a city
right I'm going trade in
my sheep for
wheat it's three wheat right for a or
three rocks he does call it SP to weat
three rocks okay so does he call it
splooge oh wait
I think so can you rewind that can we
put on the
subtitles oh here there there go
exhales
sploosh not
splooge that was telling me sploosh what
an honest mistake that is very honest
what is it liquor eight
points so it's Patrick right yeah but
his are half longest row or two another
longest row who's that other kid actor
did he do anything no he hasn't done I
haven't seen him in anything I I'm sure
he's a really cool
guy [__] I mean anyone who gets out of
child acting quick is probably
cool it's probably like yo this is by
like for Chan or
something like who sh
oh yeah he put like a camera of like he
went not dividas on a flag yeah oh they
[__] him up with that they found him
right they found it by the they found it
they found it by the planes flying
over they were able to like track the
planes that were flying over and like
and then they drove around honking their
horn so that the camera could hear it
man when they heard it they were like
it's right there and then uh he was like
going to like a public city square and
being like he will not divide us he will
not divide us and people would come and
like [__] with him or something I think
someone came and like read uh minec
comp and then like Shuff fought him he
was like sitting there reading he was
sitting there reading mcom to the camera
and Shuff fought him and got
arrested well that's a good thing that
he F
him
better get
yeah does anybody have a wheat for what
couple no Heather has all of the [__]
wheat
anybody have a
sheep yeah how do they know to go up
this [__] rock you want a brick
Legend guy was like he survived this guy
he's survive going to the top of God's
Thum I have a brick but dude that's a
[__] crazy Mountain they're climbing
right now I know but what are they going
Tock with their last cat cage or jar of
splooge a brick each other you want a
rock
SP I don't have a
wood like a pickle does anybody pickle
does anybody have a sheep no yeah I'm
not trying to [__] clim that thing
though
dude I'd rather TR figure something else
out than that dude well they're making
it more dramatic so that oh my gosh it's
more interesting to watch if it was just
a hike up a hill it wouldn't be as
dramatic
w is saying if you had to do this [__] I
would be [__] terrified I would never
do that
yeah I would drink my SPL pay $1,700 for
rent yeah you would drink your splooge
[__] I drink it then I'd walk back
pillow here
go everybody go for I hate
you
I
might well it doesn't matter but I'm
just let you know I have a victory point
because I'm a [__] idiot and I have
four points and I'm you're letting us
now yeah you roll a six yeah I roll a
six also going to play this night and
I'm going to move it where's hans's no
go for Heather no Heather's genuinely
going to win on the next roll good
Heather's genuinely going to win on the
next on our next turn for dud let me see
your cards spread them
take this one it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter she's winning I
don't think so no she's winning it
doesn't matter yeah I mean she's winning
Heather doesn't have a poker face she
doesn't have much in her life so when
she's winning she lets it be
known that's [__] mean dude okay I
I'll buy a devel c in my turn [__]
[__]
godamn four
four oh my God the kid's not that great
of an actor does anyone have any Wheat
for what don't trade with Heather she's
going to win don't give her
anything I don't want to trade with
you I trade in these for wheat and buy
development card
oh sweet mud what did you roll oh my God
he's like are they going to have to
survive there you just what did I
roll oh yeah didn't they find the to
yeah they're immediately putting their
in it
cons give me the
dice how long they only been like
[__] around in the ocean for like the
[__] dude the desert for like a
day yeah
roll here 11
11 where's the
brakes sry give me a brick
please can you hand me a
brick
plent 3
[Music]
four n n n n n okay Trade four Rock in
for sheep oh she
won
and then I'm going to play a brick a
sheep a hey if you just say she's going
to build a city it's over it doesn't
matter and I build a and I play my
victory point and no win all right and I
[__] win5 that wasn't bad for what do
we start 240 yeah do we want to play for
second place no no we don't yeah yeah
let's play for second place ready all
right it's my turn now no no no no I
rolled an eight no is he in this
movie I forgot that what's his face is
in this
movie what's his name again I love that
guy that guy right there the little dou
guy he's in Barry and uh everything
else
Henn Henry Winkler he's incredible he's
in so much [__] he's in a bunch of um a
wife and a husband can't get arrested
for the same
crime well I'm glad we got to have
Heather in the game I'm going to trat
him you guys remember when I threw
up and then I came back and won yeah
like the rest of us have the decency to
announce it when we I'm going to trade
in four for a week yeah I [__] hate
you Heather and then I'm going to trade
in four for a rock the [__] dude I
won and I'm going to play two wheat and
three Rock and with that I win second
place wow [__] face Meo didn't [__]
do that [__] I won it
win H's like I win and then that was it
I was only at Five Points I got my ass
smoked who is 6 seven how how many did
you have five also I had five where's
the chat are they congratul I had 10 I
won I had 10 I won different game these
two are off I know love
that you mean winnersville holes dude
holes
inspired the first loser yeah I have
never won a game of guitar my little
B uh that's a problem it's a real badle
yet never have I lost a game mostly luck
gu I've never G I've never lost a
gamey it's like as lucky as soccer is to
win yeah cuz they cuz everyone rolls
dice in
soccer soccer is a little more skill
based but soccer is not as skill-based
As baseball is or football or football
or basketball where are all the bags
give us give us a little bag I think the
most athletic people on the planet all
play football I that's just a fact
well in America and I think they're in
the
world
definitely players just have to do a lot
man you have to be you have to not only
be able to take a hit you're super
strong you're super fast there's a
combination you can't run for a long
periods of time the human beings can't
remember things the New Zealand All
Blacks D you forget things all the time
and then you like go on a rampage and
murder people it's [__] up dude you're
good at like being a violent chimp but
and then survival
situation you're immobile for long
periods of time it's what is that about
a
chimp we're related to you're like good
at like smashing people and like if you
get in close with them you're then
they're [__] but if they can stay away
from
you I guess the Cs just you have to be
really fast and strong that's the only
thing I know about it is the most
explosive guys the the [__] New
Zealand All black dude guys the rugby
team those guys are [__] monster they
have to do all that too and they don't
wear pads and they're New Zealander
that's different though different game
is it yeah oh I mean soccer is a fun
sport to watch but it doesn't make very
impressive is everyone's cards in the
stacks I going to say David Beckham
hottie God damn it are you my
ex-girlfriend um what I am
what about
how Americans don't always win at track
and field in the Olympics how it's a lot
of African countries or fat oh yeah for
sure but most of the people that uh that
actually participate as uh sprinters
like in the 100 and 400 a lot of them
that uh participate do play in the NFL
in fact Maris goodward who went to UT uh
I think he well I don't know he did not
do well there's a lot of other people
that did much better I didn't even watch
the last their whole career getting good
at shot put they could be good I didn't
I don't give a [__] about the Olympics
to be completely honest with you I
didn't watch a single game this I mean
the best athletes that are good at
throwing and heaving and hoing aren't
always Americans like the best wrestlers
aren't always American although a lot of
them AR well but like Russians make good
wrestlers Iranians make good wrestlers I
can't remember his name right now I feel
like an [__] uh kov uh or what's his
name the dude that wears the crazy
hatov that fought that triy to murder um
what's his Face's family at the Ring
Side Conor
McGregor he beat up Conor McGregor could
be kabib baby yeah dude what a or also
known as krenov krenov where is he from
come that out yeah where's he from again
uh dagistan it's in Russia dagistan that
dude did you I watched a video of him
just just fighting the river like a
raging River he was just fighting the
river sounds
schizophrenic it's ridiculous yeah I've
watched uh aabar the comic also do that
so I watch a person bathe a little creek
over by the creek in the cave the other
day right I was like that isn't good no
yeah that that happens a lot in the
city it's unfortunate middle oft
do you think zero is hot now definitely
definitely with that holes money
definitely he got a personal trainer and
everything got a lean
diet oh it's her [__] it's one of the
students stud is trying to kill
her why are you running so
hard you went far
back how did she get in the desert all
up she ran yeah cuz she was killing she
killed all the people she robbed a bank
and she ran that's cool then she was in
the
desert she K she kills herself with a
lizard with a lizard yeah watch a lizard
sir she lets a Lizzy she let a Lizzy
better not like a snake lizie lets Liz
[__] K those scary ass lizards too
this [__] I [__] that [__] scares me
those aren't even those aren't even V
venomous dude nah they are no they
aren't how do you know that's a regular
uh my [__] cousin has one of those
that's the whole that's the whole point
of the movie is lizards are
cool the moral of the story is lizards
lizards are pretty [__] cool look
that's just like a pet lizard dragon
that they showed on her look at that
that's like dude my [__] cousin has
one of those I swear to God it's a movie
it's just a bearded dragon a bearded
dragon dragon does have the ear
thing they added that in after
effect that's some pretty sick thing
so hes
baby it's man
oh yeah they find the treasure it's so
right I like the part with the holes the
point the point of this movie is we
[__] love
holes we're in a holes rabbit hole right
now juvenile sexual Detention
Facility [__]
holes you ever heard of
all what would they even do with that oh
yeah that guy that kid's like an orphan
he needs that money really bad dude
aren't they all orphans
no they're all [__] criminals they're
all criminals that's awesome they all
stole shoes I mean that's just you steal
shoes you dig ho hey they're Michael
Jordan
shoes oh no I'm tired
grandpa oh my God see I'm telling you
the point of the movie is lizards are
cool there's bearded dragons oh my God
they're so cute did they paint did they
they painted their backs yeah so they're
not the same
thing they all look so
cute is he smoking a
joint and is that the [__] guy from
from a scary movie too with the small
hand brother oh
brother he's on Tim Blake Nelson that
movie used to make me cry like crazy
that's my favorite movie it's so good I
just love it scary movie icky icky
sticky Bottom Boys the Soggy B Bo icky
sticky the icky sticky SP
boys maybe SP each other that's what
makes the makan
sticky am a man
of I need the join the KKK for just a
minute what was the point of that
movie go to the KKK George really
attractive is the point of that movie
and it was a wait we missed the best
part I'm tired
Grandpa
[Music]
the
prospector from cowardly the Cowardly
[Music]
Dog
[Laughter]
to oh oh my God this is like anti-white
propaganda like white people are all
disgusting evil hey hold on dude chill
[Laughter]
out not my fault you want to sh they
start leaping all over start leaping all
over Leaping
Lizards reaction literally oh crap it's
CPS
again we got to take these kids from the
where we took these we keep kidnapping
orphans
we've been thinking about it it just
seems like you're enslaving these
children
man did anybody consider child labor
laws during this what are you having to
do again uh dig holes relentlessly in
the desert no
water calloused and chapped the
flips well that is why started shooting
the lizards that is why they're digging
the holes as they were trying to find
the treasure the whole time they were
just using slaves to do it the whole
time child slaves well like who allowed
it I don't know
Madam is there still a live is there
still a chat going on right now or this
no yeah I turned it off good you can say
whatever you want okay you turned off
the
podcast oh you just turn up
chat I witnessed it myself
don't go too close oh my hey you guys
want to watch five people watch
Holes not watch it with us yo what are
you up to right now I'm watching Five
Guys watch Holes right now I'm [__]
I'm no we're just saying we're watching
holes but we're not actually watching
holes we're
watching we're watching Even
Stevens royalty wait this isn't disturb
you I love the wait how did he just jump
out Jewish Family on niol because he
realized that guys were there so they're
like I'll come out for
you yeah yeah [__] no it turns out
like the rifle founders of it or
whatever the people who found it on own
it oh yeah it has his name on
it you can read can read you can read
now I can read good
stop no zero no more I forgot about that
I'm a
tan she spent her whole life digging ho
[__] she spent her whole life digging
and now oh and now they have now she
can't take the treasure diing her own
grave and now they have a pool party you
remember
that digging up up hes di
them digging up up
hes that guy is so [__] hidden behind
that a
clipboard he's just standing there with
a clipboard and everyone's like where's
the guy what the [__] they're just going
to leave this kid there after this
[__] rapist comes over to him and
puts his hand on his shoulder he's like
we're going to take a real good care of
take your goddamn hand I'm
sorry I'm not going to this my
boy I
swear look at that
dude look look at that
dude
they're they're
alive Saks are real what a good movie
dude I saw a Tik Tok of girl mat with
zigzag on Tinder no [__]
way shoot him shoot shoot the boy look
he comes out and goes oh it was you
hiding behind the clipboard that whole
time wait a didn't see you you were
hiding so well behind that [__] 4X
two a camp what kind of a camp are you
running what kind of a slave Camp look
at that they literally just recognized
him he was hiding me on that clipboard
that's so
dumb who me yeah you stepped beh you
stepped out of the clipboard
idiot oh he got warrant
yeah well he just took my face behind
now I'm behind a jacket
[Music]
[__] they're just picking up kids from
orphanages and using them to dig
holes is
Mexican racist
movie
this
is
holes I thought Larry Nasser was the
Larry Nasser of holes just different
holes yeah we holes
[Music]
yeah wow Justice who would have guessed
no it doesn't happen not this is the
story of Epstein and
Maxwell This is an island famous
American and
now the Cur raining in the desert for
the first time cuz the racism Was
Defeated that's what happens when you
all these cops are like I don't know if
we should let these children drink water
or not every time it rains that means a
racist was taken
down it's why it never Reigns in Texas
when Shane Gillis got fired from SNL it
rained for a week I don't know if you
remember every time it every time it
rains the Angel leaves the
KKK there's a lot the KKK is running
rampant in heaven it's it's crazy dude
they got there they got their God had a
different mindset 400 years ago he let a
lot of them
[Applause]
in where is this supposed to be Texas
remember when I won yeah I think it's
supposed to be Texas awesome they're
like where do we put a dystopia in child
labor camp Texas sounds about right yeah
well it always sounds better for movies
whenever you add Texas to it like the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre the guy based at
like the murder based for that
ofn they not just all horrible thing I
don't get wait how are they not all
going home they're all getting arrested
some of them deserve to be there they
should have
complied half of them just murdered no
that would caused so many lawsuits if
that happened in real life like every F
like man that heavy of rain you have
your windows down what are you
doing
yeah it's like when I became
[Laughter]
regular
Tang dang got
arrested what is his name not I was
going to say Stanley Tucci but no wait
did they adopt him no that's
his that's his dad he's just hanging
up oh my God oh my God there's such Jews
in this moment too genuinely I'm not
even joking it's the most like
stereotypical Jewish ass [__] that
happens right now oh they bested they
got like the St they literally they get
so excited they
goik I don't I don't know the Jewish
stop
it no aome they dance around like Jewish
[Music]
people is that a lot of money at& 1905 D
[__] oh 25,000 I thought they said
2500 God they were investing in
stocks in
1905 I guess that's how the yeah you
found it you get
one I'm going to dig all
this oh where's he going get reunited
with family uh those
Ries is his mom like addicted to crack
or something what happened with his
family does anyone know the backstory I
don't know I'm sure he says it at a I
think he just stole
shoes Michael Jordan shoes not just any
shoes this is actually a prequel to like
Mike now The Bu well like he's like he's
like wandering around like the CPS place
and [__]
dude hell yeah they called it a camp
pool party
dude we didn't have water now we got a
[__]
pool hell yeah dude oh onions I thought
it was
pickles can't wait to get rich so I just
have a giant pool party dude it'd be
funny if they all just became entitled
[__] they were such sweet people before
they became billionaires Sone of his
teates evered to sit next
to that's all over
sploosh I thought it was splooge I
thought it was splooge too it's sploosh
whatever
this come on baby let me sploosh on your
face wait what did he say gives me a
tingle oh I want you to sploosh on in
me that should be a term people should
call come sploosh that's the end of the
[__] movie is that cheesy ass
commercial who even is that guy that guy
is's not even in the movie though whole
actually just capitalist propaganda
press the system it works eventually
they're like eventually hey you know
Zero's dad who was never in his life he
got a commercial out of this using his
son's money when he found out he was a
billionaire that was his dad he came
back when he found out his son guys
shoes they stole oh is that the guy oh
okay my
bad oh the Even Stevens movie bro my God
was so Z let's stay another hour 34
let's watch Steven movie she was in like
a shitty movie I watched about go back
to the chat are people still watching
this
[__] no way no people are still watching
for sure it's 4 in the
morning this whole thing
[Laughter]
is only what's
Katan
good I know you're out
there xenom dude 21st Century Girl
that's a great [__] movie great movie
Happ all remember is that with that
X who's that whose joke is it they talk
about that movie or that show Kyle XY
and it's like the whole point of that
show is that uh the guy doesn't have
yeah know he's an alien such a dumbass
show it would have been much better it's
there no [__] way just like a kid
Barbie doll dude that movie
rules I haven't seen this movie in so
long oh Johnny
Tsunami Me Oh My Disney has put out some
[__] bangers look at that [__] dude
as a kid that [__] hit me it's the
smoothest airplane ever they lube it up
that
thing dude Zenon rules she's on Earth
she feels gravity for the first time
yeah how do you how are you not [__]
up by that you would be oh she would
pass out hard she would pass out she
would immediately fall down those stairs
she be like a jellyfish yeah yeah she
just like flop like a like a just born
deer you guys watch the expanse what
year is this supposed the people that
born out in the belt they can't go on
Earth their accent is so
cheesy she fell down the stairs all
right she fell down the stairs that's
accurate it's like Jamaican right no
it's supposed to be pigeon like a a
pigeon like just like a combination of a
lot of different or like in Serenity
when they would swear in Chinese whole
me tow this thing is
broken the son is
so right are we heading out
let's end this chat on a
bang heading out we're all to bang each
other we're going to shut the chat off
and suck each other off while Heather
jerks off
watching Heather was a dick guys thanks
guys for watching thanks for watching
follow us on Instagram yeah Packer deari
on Instagram go follow go look at my
things I did a set recently on eight
tabs of acid go watch that clip Z all
really using him to watch Holes